[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à tous salut
Antoine comment tu vas salut Steph ça va
super et toi
ça va très bien
donc là on a le Nord weight chess qui
commence à l'instant avec une avec de
belles affiches déjà aujourd'hui est-ce
que tu peux Antoine nous dire un petit
peu qui sont les participants de cet
événement bah c'est quasiment tout le
top 10 mondial on a un détournois de
l'année clairement
il manque Richard rapporte quasiment
évidemment on n'a pas les deux duels du
championnat du monde je pense qu'ils
sont en train de se reposer mais on
retrouve vraiment tous les tops on
retrouve Magnus on retrouve les trois
Américains Nakamura socawana il y a
chariyamadia ROV qui est toujours un
joueur super agréable à avoir joué côté
français on a bien sûr le crack Ali résa
firuggia Mad Maxime malheureusement mais
on a quand même allé résa c'est pas mal
et celui qui pour moi est peut-être le
favori du tournoi c'est noirebex
qu'est-ce que tu en penses ouais de ouf
alors là juste en train de me dire dans
l'oreillette que ton son il est pas ouf
et que ça grésille
est-ce que tu peux peut-être éloigner un
peu ton micro c'est le micro de ton
casque ouais peut-être essayer
d'éloigner un petit peu
éloigné j'ai éloigné là pour pas que ça
dure est-ce que ça va mieux
mais
je pense que moi
je suis déjà aux anges puisque Magnus a
envoyé une française alors la fameuse
française donc ça c'est quand même une
chose d'ouverture à ça intéressant de la
part de Magnus parce que c'est vrai que
la française bah écoute c'est une
ouverture qui qui joue un petit peu
comment dire un peu tous les résultats
parce que si nous aventure un petit peu
sous-estimée qui est terminé la mode
d'ailleurs par par dépôt lors de masse
et candidat qui a pas mal et puis et
puis là c'est vrai que la française ben
c'est pas le 4 5 avec la petite
berlinoise où on fait nulle etc là ça
joue donc
on rentre dans la grande variante bolet
slavski qui est une des plus
intéressantes on avait pas mal aussi
rapporte jouer ça au dernier tournoi en
Roumanie et il y a eu il a eu de très
bons résultats c'est pas du tout réfuté
même au plus haut niveau la française
donc je suis très très excité à l'idée e
de voir Magnus jouer ça aujourd'hui il a
choisi la balance avec A6
alors cette vente de la française écoute
les jeux pendant 10 ans
avec les Noirs
donc bon j'étais gosse donc c'est pas
vraiment le la ligne que j'ai bossé
jusqu'au 40e coup mais je connais pas
mal ces positions et c'est les positions
qui sont intéressantes d'ailleurs je le
souhaite partir
contre mail vous voyez on a il y a
quelques quelques mois d'ici là
j'ai entendu parler de cette partie
j'ai peut-être un ami qui joue pour
Aix-en-Provence peut-être ouais non mais
c'était une partie c'est une partie
plutôt sympa pour le coup j'ai pas mal
joué donc
une variante avec Dame B6 ici et les
blancs font Caval à 4 damasake alors C3
et c'est super intéressant aussi
et je crois qu'il y a un prise on joue
P4 intermédiaire il me semble cavalier
prend B4 et alors je crois que c'était
l'ancienne ligne qui se joue plus
actuellement il me semble en tête je me
trompe à haut niveau c'est réfuter
l'ordinateur donne plus 0,7 je pense
mais en amateur elle se joue encore
alors je sais plus comment ça se joue
hein c'est un truc du style comme ça et
en fait tu as vachement de pions avec
les noirs et c'est pas facile en
pratique pour développer et tout mais
donc ça c'est mis un petit peu chaude et
moi avec les Blancs ici je veux pas
Caval A4 écoute moi je joue à 3
oui à trois qui empêchent de prendre B2
en fait
je t'invite chez moi et si tu viens en
B2 bah écoute là j'ai cavaliers 4 qui va
t'enfermer
la dame quoi et c'est la catastrophe
c'est perdu autre ligne super
intéressante pour les blancs c'est Dame
des deux ici qui donne le pion B2 et là
il faut le prendre
ou alors généralement quand tu arrives à
attaquer la tour et le cavalier c'est
généralement le le bon plan et sur ça
dans ma 5 il y a le cavalier B5
peut-être
B5 dame prend à deux
ok je connais pas
bon en tout cas c'est chaud hein
avec A6 ce qui a été joué pas mal par
Bacro aussi il me semble ces derniers
temps ok ok possible
et ça fait réfléchir Fabienne au déjà et
ouais parce que bon ben ça va pas
forcément à ce que Magnus joue une
Française donc vous savez que les
joueurs bah se préparent à chaque partie
il y a une préparation chaque partie on
essaie de deviner un peu ce qu'on va
faire l'adversaire
et bon bah Magnus la française bon bah
c'est pas bon c'est pas impossible la
preuve mais c'est pas non plus c'était
pas une science sur c'était pas le cas
du tout et d'ailleurs c'est un peu une
surprise j'ai envie de dire clairement
on l'attend plutôt sur la Sicilienne ou
sur E5
lignes de l'espagnol et ça fait plaisir
de le voir changer un peu surtout contre
un adversaire aussi fort que Kanana
[Musique]
mais en jouant cavalier 2 et bien il va
essayer de sortir Magnus de sa
préparation donc c'est aussi un combat
psychologique en début de partie
donc on est déjà dans une ligne qui est
très très peu jouée effectivement
là dans la base de données on trouve
plus qu'une vingtaine de parties déjà
alors qu'on est même pas au dixième coup
donc ça c'est une que je connais enfin
j'avais vu déjà vu des trucs comme ça
l'idée c'est de faire C3 et essayer de
de consolider très vite la chaîne de
pions et des fois d'arriver un cavalier
donc très vite donc ça peut être avec
cavalier 3 mais aussi il y a plein
d'idées avec du G3 fois pour taper avec
F5 et moi cavalier F4 très rapidement et
ça peut être très dangereux donc voilà
donc là je par contre je n'ai aucune
idée de comment ça se joue avec les
Noirs cette pause alors si je dois
manger réagir tout ça je B5 ou en fait
la rupture habituelle avec F6 marche pas
trop quand le centre est bien soutenu
par F4 et D4 donc il va falloir jouer à
l'eldame il y a pas vraiment le choix ou
alors ou alors peut-être envoyer des G5
mais alors là c'est des lignes que je
connais que je connais pas bien et qui
me paraissent très risqué alors je sens
que c'est un coup qui a systématique
dans cette potion de France alors
pourquoi en fait peut-être pas
maintenant je sais pas si on fait H6 G5
direct juste pour expliquer un petit peu
ce qui se passe et pourquoi l'idée déjà
5 pourraient être une idée c'est qu'en
fait on veut casser un petit peu le
centre des blancs et si les blancs
mangent du pion ou du cavalier et ben
inévitablement le centre de pion voit un
peu exploser vous voyez que le pion est
plus puissant 5 et par exemple ici je
peux commencer à tout casser là et une
fois que tu manges avec une pièce là et
ben il y a lui qui tombe par exemple
donc c'est un sacrifice d'un pion de
l'aile pour gagner un peu au centre mais
attention que j'ai quand même pas bien
sorti des pièces et que du coup et ben
la position si elle s'ouvre au centre ça
peut être compliqué et
pardon
sur les cases blanches en fait si les
blancs arrivent à arriver avec damage 5
le fou en D3 et qu'on n'a pas encore
géré notre contre jeux à eldam ça arrive
très très vite sur nos trois qu'on est
OK ou pas d'ailleurs
on vous a mis de ce qui est un peu en
plus grand en mode Corse pof après moi
j'ai sur mon overlay j'ai pas mal de
scène donc on pourra aller se balader un
petit peu si vous voulez à travers à
travers toutes nos scènes en tout cas on
a on a un super overlay aujourd'hui je
suis très content pour la trouver Harley
ce qu'on peut vous montrer les caméras
des joueurs etc on a malus qui est un
petit peu hors cadre mais bon ça je suis
pour rien je peux pas vous le recadrer
mais
on a vraiment un très bel overly
aujourd'hui en tout cas vous allez
pouvoir voir tout ça
et là c'est Magnus qui réfléchit qui
semble avoir été un peu surpris
peut-être par le dame CE1 de Fabiano
alors que pourtant c'est le coup le plus
joué dans cette position et déjà c'est
bien on l'a des joueurs qui
réfléchissent finalement les prépas
devaient pas aller bien loin aujourd'hui
je pense et
un peu grillé tu vois des fois c'est des
fois c'est pas mal de
de comment dire de 21 un petit peu
l'adversaire parce que je vois pas
encore psychologiquement c'est important
si on joue tout tempo la Barça il va
savoir que tu es exactement dans ta
préparation et à un moment donné il va
dévier le fait de réfléchir un petit peu
ça te permet premièrement de rentrer
dans la partie donc déjà de bien te
concentrer etc rentrer dedans et
deuxièmement ça permet aussi de bon j'ai
refait des lignes mais aussi peut-être
de pas trop montrer à l'adversaire que
tu connais bien ou pas bien tu vois donc
ça permet un petit peu quand même de
ça entre assis au niveau qu'ils ont
besoin de se cacher après je pense
après il y a plusieurs plusieurs types
de joueurs tu as mvl qui fait tout tempo
quand il est dans la prépa Guiri fait
pas ça donc
il est plus ça dépend des joueurs je
pense ça dépend des joueurs tu vois ben
tu as le profil plutôt de mvl et de
dépôt généralement assez vite quand ils
sont dans leur truc après tu as le
profil peut-être plus car wanna Magnus
guéri ou qui prennent plus leur temps tu
vois mais c'est un petit peu voilà alors
les oiseaux c'est pas sur le stream
c'est ma fenêtre mais
qu'on me demande sans privé
qu'apparemment
[Musique]
et salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
quand je poste gare aux cannes mythe du
44 qu'elle a
on est pour l'instant sur la partie car
wash and
donc est-ce que tu poses un petit tour
des stades un peu ce qui se passe dans
les autres les autres parties
si tu veux on peut aller on peut aller
voir un peu ce qui se passe bah tiens on
a on a une partie qui est intéressante
c'est c'est
so gooche qui est qui est ici non
attends
pourquoi ils m'ont mis ça ici je vais
sur la route plus simple voilà et en
deuxième table on a un avis resa Google
sur ça c'est vraiment un
appareillagement qui est qui est très
très intéressant parce que il m'a encore
changé
ouais en fait là j'ai tout inversé
c'est juste les deux meilleurs juniors
du monde tout simplement
voilà c'est les deux meilleurs juniors
du monde c'est clair les deux ont les
deux genres en 18 ans on a goût cache
qui est bon genre indien qui est qui a
commencé depuis un an ou deux
complètement explosé au niveau
au niveau checker il était à 2600 il y a
pas longtemps et là boum 2016 30 il a
fait des incroyable c'est vraiment avec
tout meilleur et puis bah filou
2 ans de de plus mais on oublie souvent
que ferrugia il a encore junior en fait
parce qu'il est au top depuis tellement
longtemps cette année il aurait pu faire
les France juniors si vous voulez par
exemple c'est ça ben ouais bon alors
aucun sens mais il aurait pu
donc oui non
enfin il vient d'avoir 17 d'ailleurs il
a eu 10 il a eu 17 je crois c'était pas
de bêtises Google
avant-hier ou hier un truc comme ça je
l'ai vu passer sur sur les réseaux et je
crois je crois qu'il est passé enfin il
a eu 17 ans ah c'était hier voilà
mais il est il a 2 ans de moins que
firou un sirop qui va sur le 19
sacrée barbe en tout cas pour 17 ans je
sais pas si vous aviez la même moi non
et ils sont sur une italienne assez
calme en fait Djoko pianissimo si je ne
m'abuse
donc oui là voilà c'est la fameuse
italienne donc là c'est intéressant le
A4 qui vend de jouer ici
bouquet parce qu'on avait pas mal
d'idées l'idée ici c'est que A5 mois ici
on joue à 5 hop avec les Noirs donc
souvent avec les Blancs on peut jouer du
A3 ou à 4 d'ailleurs ici le 25 noir il
est pas obligatoire quand on a plusieurs
possibilités avec A6 ou à 5 et les deux
coups ont avantages inconvénients l'idée
d'un 5e t'empêcher aussi l'expansion B4
et
et à 6 aussi c'est un autre idée qu'on
peut avoir pour prendre la case du Fou
B5 et faire éventuellement un cavalier
A5 qui va manger le petit fou en B3 et
donc sur A5 ici c'est vrai que un des
coûts qui est beaucoup joué avec les
Blancs c'est A3 A4 aussi pour essayer de
garder ce fou un petit peu envie
et ici le coup tourera rock on va voir
cavalier F1 normal et à 4 je parlais
noir et ça empêche la retraite du Fou en
B3 donc
après à 4 bah là il faut se poser des
questions savoir qu'est-ce qu'on joue
parce cavalier à 5
ça pose problème parce que ça ça
s'attaque le fou il le faut la pas de
casse pour sortir à moins qu'on puisse
jouer cavaler à 5 fou B5 allait manger
en A4 mais je sais pas gourmand
ben en fait je sais pas si vraiment
parce que sur ça on va sûrement je fous
de 7 pour qu'elle me défendre le pion
dessert
est-ce que c'est intéressant ou pas je
ne sais pas
faut prendre à me prendre et quelle est
cette pause je préfère les blancs quand
même ouais c'est on sait pas vraiment si
l'échange des fous ici va
avantager ou pas
radio c'était hier et qu'il l'a fêté
avec une petite victoire sur Carlson en
blitz c'était bien hier la classe et
donc voilà donc en fait là moi je sais
pas moi j'ai envie de jouer de manière
un peu automatique j'aurais à trois
tu veux empêcher à trois en fait
une case pour le fou tu vois avec les
Noirs là on n'a pas envie de faire à
trois sinon on se prend juste B4
[Musique]
ouais mais en fait là moi ce que je vais
faire c'est pas à trois je vais faire
cavaler à 5 et je sais pas comment en
fait je suis pas sûr que l'échange des
fous comme ça soit bien pour les blancs
je peux mettre mon foulard
mais au final j'aime pas le quoi 3 parce
que sur A3 je pense qu'il y a un coup
très fort
qui pourrait être éventuellement
cavalier à 5 et sur fou à deux qui était
mon idée peut-être que j'ai fous aussi
et sur le long terme ici pouvoir essayer
de le capturer enfin contrôler la case
B3 et est-ce qu'on remettrait pas le fou
en B1
non
fermait
même en plus essayer d'avoir d'avoir
cette casse c'est mon idée mais je suis
pas sûr faut calculer un prise prise
d'un point A4 ça il y a un vis-à-vis
mais bon pion c'est un pion et je me
lasse B4 est-ce que vraiment c'est
valable ou pas je sais pas en tout cas
il a juste fou B5 qui attaque le pion il
tient bah écoute moi je mange champion
démerde-toi comment tu le défends alors
bah si je fais à trois quand tu l'as dit
tête B4 qui va arriver
là j'ai même une idée du type peut-être
fou B3 enfin faut A4 pour aller manger
là c'est un peu gourmand c'est un peu
long mais écoute une fois que je fais ça
j'ai pris un pion quoi ouais c'est pas
très grave que ça soit long parce que
j'ai pas l'impression que les Noirs ont
un plan immédiat quoi très concret non
peut-être l'idée c'est que là j'ai quand
même réussi à affaiblir ces trois grâce
à grâce à la carte peut-être la poussée
des 5 pour être possible essayer de
prendre cavalier prend mais ça m'a l'air
un peu compliqué en plus avec des cinq
classes j'ai 50 prises tout le temps il
y a des faux processus qu'elle va les
prendre à 5 ça m'a l'air chelou mais on
voit que la la jauge vous savez qu'on a
toujours la petite jauge petite barre
qui est ici
et en fait et ben
toujours des ressources de toute façon
dans tous types de position ici quand
même j'ai l'impression que même sur D5
avec les Blancs j'ai juste envie de
faire cavalier G3 même je te laisse
prendre en 4 si tu veux je
me sens pas particulièrement inquiet je
vais gagner le pion à 3 jours ouais je
pense que tu vas gagner puis tu as aussi
depuis le 5 qui va être faible là je
pensais à un gavage G4 avec essayer de
taper sur F5
et peut-être faire un jour du
F5 derrière je sais pas
et après il faut que si les Noirs font
des 5 pour leur contre-jour on a aussi
des idées de fous prends un C6 qui va
qui va
qui va vraiment fragiliser la structure
la structure noire à eldam une fois que
les pions CD serait CB seront doublés
tu pourras plus déconnecter le pion
dessin quoi sinon il devient trop faible
c'est de la
non non je gagne curieux de voir comment
il va réagir Google je parce que ça m'a
l'air pas facile mais bon lui bien sûr
qu'il a coûté un peu c'est clairement
une position qu'il a travaillé donc on
va voir un peu chasseur de voir comment
il va comment il va il va se débrouiller
parce que là ça a pas la facile la ligne
qu'on évoqué a été jouée c'est la partie
c'est la partie et ça c'est quand même
c'est intéressant a déjà réfléchi pas
mal il a réfléchi un bon quart d'heure
là-dessus donc ça veut dire qu'il est il
est pas dans une prépa quelconque
je pense pas qu'on tu parlais de bluffer
un peu tout à l'heure mais je pense pas
qu'on puisse le se permettre de bluffer
un quart d'heure dans une partie qui je
vous le rappelle c'est deux heures KO
avec un peu de crème à partir de 40e
coup ouais alors en fait la cadence oui
la cadence importante la cadence c'est
2h ko donc là vous voyez qu'il y a 1h44
et une heure 55 c'est du chaos il y a
pas de temps mais à partir de 40e coup
et ben les joueurs auront 10 secondes à
chaque coup donc pour les règles de avec
10 secondes par coup donc moi je suis
pas arbitre je vais quand même vous la
faire
quand on a moins de 5 minutes à la
pendule et ben je peux arrêter de noter
mes coups
donc ça va être la règle parce qu'avec
10 secondes tu imagines tu as 10
secondes plus 10 secondes par coup
comment que notre technique c'est
compliqué
donc voilà en tout cas on va voir un peu
comment ça se passe mais ça va être
sympa parce que
c'est un format lent avec qui va se
terminer à la fin en blitz donc c'est
assez intéressant et d'ailleurs on vous
rappelle que en cas de match nul
et management vont s'affronter en
Armageddon donc vous avez ici toutes les
informations si vous voulez vous voulez
je peux vous les montrer rapidement
donc les participants sont ici vous les
connaissez tous un manuscade trois fois
champion
saut deux fois champion on a aussi à
lire Raisa le français Hikaru anus
grisotorov Ariane tari et goket le
format je vous le montre aussi on a 10
joueurs qu'il faut 50 ans toute ronde
donc là c'est format BL itz j'ai pas mis
à jour désolé mais c'est un format tout
tronc aussi de façon donc ça a pas
changé grand chose là les le classement
qui n'est bien sûr pas à jour parce
qu'elle est partie pas encore été jouée
et
vous avez ici les appareils
donc en cas de départage vous avez
vous avez les
comment dire les
l'armagidon
en fait on va voir 7 minutes et les
Noirs non c'est le contraire les blancs
vont avoir 10 minutes et les Noirs 7
minutes et en cas de nul les les Noirs
gays le match en fait le minimum
ouais et pour les points alors je vais
remettre la scène
pour pour les points c'est assez simple
si un joueur gagne la partie donc la
partie qui joue ici
en partie lente et ben il gagne 3 points
si il perd et ben il perd enfin il gagne
par contre si on fait match nul dans la
partie lente qu'après on joue en
Armageddon le gain de l'Armageddon
gagnera un point et demi donc un point
de la nul plus un demi point
un demi point
pour pour le gagnant et le perdant aura
seulement un point alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on regarde la passion Google parce
qu'on regarde en fait c'est simple mon
overlay et ben il est comme ça j'ai
blanc en bas et le problème c'est que si
je mets les blancs en bas vous allez pas
avoir le temps passer le temps vous le
voyez mais vous avez goût cache et Ali
resa qui sont ici en fait il faudrait
que je enfin quand j'ai réglé
apparemment je l'ai
fait que je décolle les trucs
donc en fait ce qu'il faudrait je vais
essayer de le faire c'est changer de
place les
[Musique]
images que je me suis bien embêté à tout
mettre en place avant
et là on pourra vous mettre en bas à
l'irza quand même le joueur français en
bas
et c'est ce qu'on cherche à faire
intéressants de jouer sur la partie
carwana Carlsen qu'on suivait au tout
début
Magnus évidemment Fabiano a choisi de
soutenir son pion central avec C3 on en
avait parlé tout à l'heure
et je vais dire ok il a choisi de roquet
de s'exposer à une éventuelle attaque
blanche
ouais
j'ai enlevé ce qu'il fallait pas me
tromper
c'est pas sac avec je change c'était le
nom des joueurs et moi j'ai changé
pour vous faire un peu de radio pendant
que tu fallait main dans le cambouis
côté
nakasso on a sans surprise une
berlinoise inintéressante et à mon avis
c'est deux mecs vont faire nul très
rapidement
côté Abdou sa torov et guéri
j'ai bien peur qu'on n'est pas beaucoup
de velléité non plus on est dans un
gambidam refusé
tout ce qu'il y a de plus normal mais ça
peut ça peut convenir au style de nos
dire Beck qu'un grand technicien
ma métarie on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
d'Ariane tari mais il est possible que
ça soit un peu le penalty du tournoi le
pauvre il est quand même un grand au
dessus de tous les autres ouais mais
chaque année quand même il se bat bien
oui
champion du monde junior face à très
très fort joueur bien sûr
ouais chaque année en fait il est là
c'est difficile pour le chaque fois mais
à chaque fois il est pas ridicule
donc un petit peu ce qui nous fait alors
je vous ai mis le camp blanc ça y est je
vous ai mis à livraison en bas
et puis on va aller voir un peu si vous
voulez ce qui se passe à côté les autres
les autres parties pour aller voir un
peu ce qui se passe chez
qu'est-ce que tu vas aller voir est-ce
que tu veux qu'on aille voir dis-moi je
viens d'aller faire un tour et pour moi
la plus intéressante et ce n'est pas
parce que je suis fan de français mais
peut-être un peu c'est vraiment celle
entre Kawan avec Carlson la carwana
vient d'envoyer G3 et avec l'idée comme
tu disais tout à l'heure peut-être de
faire fouash 3 et F5 un jour et je
trouve que c'est super intéressant comme
position on va revenir ici
et
voilà les joueurs sont bien
c'est fascinant comme position tellement
de possibilités
donc carlsel qui a abandonné toutes les
idées de plan de jeu alléluia puisqu'il
a rocket maintenant il va pas pousser
ses pions ou alors dans très longtemps
problème il a la dame en B6 qui fait pas
grand chose maintenant et qui empêche le
pion B de pousser pour continuer pour
prendre de l'espace sur les dames
et là le plan de carwana est à peine
caché c'est fou je crois pour faire F5
je pense l'ordinateur adorait à la place
de G3 il adorait acheter 4 trouver que
c'était un coup très très fort
très thématique dans la française ce
petit H4 qui permet de prendre de
l'espace et de d'avoir des cases pour le
Cavaillon en G5 et aussi des fois H4 H5
et H6 et il y a même des fois des idées
où tu peux faire tout rage 3 et ton jeu
3 donc c'est un goût en fait assez
flexible H3 et quand la position est
fermée et ben je peux me je peux me
comment dire je peux me permettre de
faire sur deux coups donc
j'ai trois c'est plus c'est plus calme
comme coup mais ça empêche pas de faire
la suite évidemment
après il va y avoir la question de ce
cavalier E2 qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
parce qu'il va pas rester là toute la
vie il va falloir qu'il laisse un peu de
place
[Musique]
le roi va aller en F2 c'est possible ça
non souvent le roi ils vont F2
effectivement
très souvent le roi vend un F2 alors
attends je vais mettre une je vais vous
montrer un petit peu les scènes qu'on
peut avoir on a plein de scènes
différentes
dans laquelle je peux vous montrer
je vais montrer un petit peu ce qu'on a
un si vous voulez voir un petit peu ce
qu'on voulait faire un petit tour
rapidement sur les parties je peux vous
montrer celle-là petite scène ici qui
est sympa avec toutes les parties qui
sont en direct vous voyez donc on a
travaillé nos carbona blanc contre
Karlsen on va à côté à firouza on voit
maintenant ma média off qui faisait
partie aussi et je pense quand j'ai pas
vu la partie de ma média off mais c'est
bon c'est un gamme classique
et ben c'est une position avec pion
isolé
et
on a Wester sceau carvana je pense que
ça va être la turbodro hein ils sont
dans leur dans leur petite
ouverture là qui est hyper hyper joué là
d'espagnol enfin je vais essayer de
faire un petit truc parce qu'on parle de
mon
[Musique]
de mon ordi déjà
je sais pas si ça résonne c'est chez moi
aussi c'est chez toi je pense plutôt
chez toi
je sais pas il y a quelqu'un dans le
chat qui a dit que ça résonnait
ok je voulais voir un truc
je vais passer sur une scène
[Musique]
je vais vous montrer un petit peu
ça sur celle-là pendant que je vais
faire un petit truc j'ai besoin de me
cacher un peu pendant une petite seconde
et pendant ce temps là je vais essayer
d'aller voir si je peux changer mon truc
en caméra
donc on voit la partie de Carlsen avec
au dessus de karena qui est ici
pendant que j'essaie de
changer un truc
ok Carlsen super intéressant café F6
tout de suite
qu'elle fait F6 tout de suite
on est encore dans le
dans des parties jouées et d'ailleurs
quand on regarde dans la base de données
c'est intéressant il y a que des grands
maîtres qui ont joué cette position
ok bah j'imagine que pour rentrer
là-dedans il faut quand même connaître
savoir un peu ce que tu fais
ah tu aimes bien cette scène patoche
je viens de changer un truc sur mon sur
mon discord est-ce que si je
clique est-ce que vous entendez ma
souris
est-ce que si je j'appuie dans mon
clavier
vous entendez mon clavier
s'il vous plaît c'est un question
importante
ouais moi j'entends un peu donc ils
doivent entendre un peu aussi parce que
du coup je change un truc mais c'est pas
que j'entendais j'imagine que vous
entendez beaucoup alors c'est c'est
gênant ou pas c'est gênant
ça c'est très gênant salut lotus blanc
sur une échelle de 1 à 10 et je n'en
comment
beaucoup c'est gênant
son mec c'était 7 ah ouais c'est
beaucoup quand même
t'as pas un suppresseur de bruit là dans
tes options qui supprime les bruits
ambiants alors normalement ça je le
faisais sur discord avec Chris
et je l'ai fait mais ça me suffit pas
d'argent depuis longtemps
je vais quand même enlever mon micro je
vais mettre je vais enlever le bruit
mais normalement
[Musique]
ça va
et je viens d'avoir d'ailleurs une
petite confession tu sais qu'on en a
parlé hier
donc j'ai fait un truc est-ce que est-ce
que maintenant je viens de faire un truc
est-ce que maintenant quand je clique
sur le clavier est-ce que ça fait encore
un petit bruit où est-ce que c'est pas
gênant
vas-y appuie clique j'ai cliqué j'appuie
ah ouais on entend plus c'est bon j'ai
réussi à parler d'eux
et voilà
un micro digne de ce nom
voilà donc c'est mon mieux mais c'est
vrai que j'avais ce problème sur
discord je l'avais réparé c'était revenu
mais en fait tu sais que mon micro on
l'a vu hier et encore aujourd'hui des
fois mon micro et ben il se déconnecte
lui-même tout seul de Obs et je dois le
reparamétrage à chaque fois encore et ça
c'est l'angoisse et je pense que c'est
ce qui m'est arrivé en fait j'ai perdu
le truc et j'ai dû tout refaire bon en
tout cas
il s'est passé un truc assez intéressant
sur la partie Dali resa c'est qu'après
11 bonnes minutes de réflexion il a
décidé de remettre son fou sur la
diagonale a2f7
ah mais du coup alors on va revenir sur
la partie
je pense que c'est intéressant
là j'avoue que attends
il considère que le pion plus tard
manger et une fois qu'il a fait à trois
ben il est commit et maintenant pourquoi
pas ramener le four
donc alors maintenant l'idée pourquoi
est-ce que on va essayer de voir
pourquoi est-ce que ici
on voit plus tous
si la scène normalement je suis en haut
là enfin juste pas bouger
mais sur sur quoi A4 je menace peut-être
vous prendre à trois mais c'est un peu
compliqué il y a quand même plusieurs
plusieurs enfin si il y a des fous en
brochette là c'est pas clair
[Musique]
comment est-ce qu'on comment est-ce
qu'on joue
loin un truc
parce que depuis
je comprends pas le cavale si le cavale
je comprends il va il va enlever si
c'est peut-être un jour en F4 ça c'est
le parcours normal du cavalier dans ce
genre de structure
mais là en fait il laisse pas au blanc
la chance de faire dame B3 en premier
tempo 6
dans la partie là où on est maintenant
là
pour voir si pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
pas manger plus en fait oui excuse-moi
ouais mais
4 et tu vas peut-être manger froid et la
dame doit défendre les deux trucs en
même temps
peut-être que faut pas se presser en
fait au pire tu remets le cavalent des
deux ouais mais bon c'est
juste pour manger un pion ça je trouve
ça dommage effectivement mes pièces sont
éparpillées et puis il y aura quand même
un dessin qui peut arriver
non en fait là ce que fait Ali raisin il
replace le courant C4 et il va être
tranquillement j'ai droit à je crois
avoir un peu ce qui se passe par jour
par des cartes et il se dit que ce pion
peut-être sur le long terme et ben il
sera faible et je pourrais aller le
manger mais si je te fais dames Détroit
tout madame B3 pardon tout de suite ok
madame B3 tout de suite alors faut voir
faut faire attention aux autres quand
même
peuvent peut-être aussi être privés
mais je pense qu'en fait je pense que il
me donne un
et il va vouloir faire quelque chose
ailleurs
quoi intéressant mais il va donner le
plus en fait pendant qu'il va manger à 3
et ben il compte faire autre chose donc
ailleurs c'est pas évident
pas mon idée de MP3 sans surprise
peut-être commencer par un petit coup de
foue 3 pour empêcher toutes les
histoires sur la
sur la diagonale noire
et c'est en l'occurrence c'est un peu
une menace enfin tu peux pas ne rien
faire avec les Noirs tu es obligé de
prendre ce fou tu dois pas quelque chose
parce que tu attends
donc il faut trouver quelque chose de
concret quand même mais en fait un plan
que tu peux avoir cette plante tu parles
toutes ces pièces manger là-bas tu perds
10 ans tu as peut-être juste bouger mon
roi faire ça faire cavaler là il me la
CM2
commencer à monter la terre sur le roi
pendant que toutes les pièces sont
parties H3 alors H3 oui je pense ça
empêche mais attention que il y a un
problème sur F2 et H3 ça ouvre aussi des
cases noires donc faire attention avec
H3 il peut y avoir des fois à d'autres
menaces même imaginer même être
sacrifice sur H3 et comme mon plan c'est
de faire F5 un jour
en fait à l'ireza il a un grand un grand
choix il est au carrefour des chemins
stratégiques là
est-ce que bref il va sans doute pas
aller croquer puis à trois en fait pas
dans un proche futur en fait là il faut
qu'il s'occupe de ce qui va se passer à
l'aile droite je pense
parce que finalement ça va arriver assez
vite peut-être même que que Google a
prévu de jouer avec des G5 G4
j'ai du mal à imaginer ça pour l'instant
non
je sais pas moi je trouve c'est un plan
que je vois souvent dans les Italiens
quand même mais là on a pris
assez tôt pour vite ok G4 tout ça et il
y a un combat au centre mais là là je
sais pas je le vois pas du tout moi je
pense
4 et mettre un truc en F4 là en plus
c'est mieux de le faire quand il y a un
fou un G5 parce qu'en plus tu gagnes des
thèmes pour la série que c'est pas très
intéressant
perdre plein de temps à faire ça bah moi
pendant ce temps là je vais essayer
d'attaquer ton doigt donc c'est un peu
dans l'esprit mais je sens que j'aime
pas mais je pense que c'est ton esprit
quand même de
patoche qui nous demande en belge si on
peut remontrer la partie depuis je sais
vous montrer la partie alors je vais
depuis le début et hop ah non je pardon
voilà j'ai cheesecom vous savez
automatique il va vous montrer comment
ça se passe
alors C3 donc l'italienne classique
cavalier 2
et on a plein de parties intéressantes
tu vois celle-là c'est un peu une partie
vraiment très importante dans le sens où
concrètement il y a un pont qui va te
perdu chez les chez les noirs et là
j'aime beaucoup l'idée de goûter en fait
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de venin
encore avec lui ça prépare va très loin
là ben c'est possible mais tu vois un
joueur bon comme Google qui est tout
nouveau dans le circuit qui a 2730 qui
vient d'avoir 17 ans je doute qu'il
perde un pion dans les italiens comme ça
surtout alors c'est lui qui est parti
perdre ce pion tu vois mais tu vois à
les raisins il s'en occupe pas du tout
de ce pion il joue cavale G3
en fait ce pion non mais en fait je
pense qu'il a compris un peu l'idée
c'est que quand tu vas manger le pion le
noir vont attaquer le roi pendant que
toutes les pièces blanches seront ici
ben il a compris ces pièces et puis
après sur le long terme peut-être qu'à
un moment donné je pourrais aller manger
le pain mais il stresse pas et je pense
qu'il a raison de pas se presser
et voilà oui ben à trois styles alpha
zéro maintenant avec tous les gros
modules très très forts
arrivés en H5 H6 ou
à 4 à 3 dans de côté dans toutes les
ouvertures
donc donc voilà ça c'est vrai que ça
c'est un truc qui peut être analysé et
donc avoir un petit peu comment ça se
passe il y a de Chessy groove qui nous
fait remarquer qu'on entend un nouveau
ton clavier
mon clavier si on entend c'est bien
parce que je l'ai pas touché
mais on entend des clics
j'entends des clics et tout pourtant je
viens de quand même de de
un truc ouais ce que ça ne marche pas
la mes filtres là j'ai quand même
enlever
c'était pas dans ta rue parce que là
normalement
ouais c'est apparu moi a priori c'était
que ça
bonjour à tous
malekil il y a une route qui est arrivé
non c'est un micro qui est pas
d'ordinateur portable c'est
c'est
un micro un micro
c'est compliqué parce qu'on l'a des
informations très contrastées dans le
chat il y en a qui disent rien d'autre
horrible
compliqué allez bon on va continuer
comme ça on va parler chèque tant pis
peut-être que si je
peut-être non mais c'est des cliques
apparemment ça déclic
c'est pas que je tape mon bureau
ok bon on va continuer comme ça de toute
façon
alors donc ouais donc tu vois que ça
prend pas la tête et
il joue normal quoi
donc ok intéressant j'aime aussi
beaucoup ce qui se passe côté carwada
Carl send si je sais pas si tu veux
peut-être aller voir d'autres mais moi
celle-là je l'adore ouais
rapidement sur carwana Carson
la deuxième grosse réflexion pour
l'italo américain qui a après j'ai trois
fait fou j'ai deux donc il choisit un
plan quand même assez modeste
assez calme il a pas trop envie de
mettre le roi en F2 maintenant parce que
il y a un pion F6 qui va vouloir prendre
5 ouvrir la colonne F sans doute
les Noirs ont égalisés
[Musique]
mais
en tout cas c'est les potions qui sont
très compliquées alors vu que cette
position a été jouée deux fois dans
l'histoire des échecs je pense que
personne n'en est vraiment un
spécialiste c'est incroyable ils sont
quasiment en territoire inexploré là au
12e
15 minutes quand même absolument savoir
ce qu'il fait je pense car voilà un peu
moins peut-être mais bon quand même je
pense que
ils doivent quand même connaître enfin
capable de cette Lina je pense que ils
connaissent les idées profondes bien sûr
mais cette position là et de l'ont
forcément jamais eu sur sur l'échiquier
c'est intéressant je pense que
maintenant Carlsen va sans doute ou
vouloir ouvrir la colonne C en fait
problème maintenant c'est son cavalier
17 en fait il va où lui
cavaler il aime bien prendre en F6 quand
les blancs prennent mais là les blancs
vont pas prendre avec le soutien qu'ils
ont depuis un E5 ils ont soutient des
deux côtés ils ont aucune raison de
prendre un F6
en fait ce qui va se passer souvent
c'est que les Noirs vont jouer F6
et voir un peu s'il le centre arrive à
tout se casser quoi
mais c'est une bonne remarque de ta part
je sais pas
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un système
avec un jour manger en des quatre f-6
vraiment le 5 et que puis on va manger
un des quatre
mais on l'a déjà fait 6 dans cette
position
je suis en retard j'avais pas vu
effectivement donc on se rapproche on se
rapproche doucement de casser ce centre
mais il va rester des là par exemple si
il prend des quatre c'est prendre des
quatre F prend E5 F-5 bah le centre
demeure quand même mais ce cavalier 17
n'a toujours pas de case
faire attention à tous ces trucs là je
pense presque comme cavalier prend un
sac qui ne marche pas pour l'instant la
prise le fou des produits par hasard et
faire attention petite
[Musique]
mais ça c'est un thème tactique que qui
marche souvent dans la française dans la
bolet slavski sauf que là la dame c'est
un qui défendent le B2 elle a aussi le
mérite de défendre le fouet 3
intéressant mais effectivement tant
qu'on a pas résolu le problème de ce
cavalier d'essai c'est pas le foot casse
blanche bon c'est jamais le bon fout de
la française mais on aimerait bien un
jour qui qui fasse une petite partie
quand même c'est à base de foot et 7 x 8
fou G6 ou simplement foutez cette fou B5
pour juste s'activer ou s'échanger
contre une pièce mineure blanche
et ben il va falloir faire un truc avec
le cavale ça il y a pas le choix mais en
tout cas c'était des positions assez
profondes et
ultra ultra complexe genre mémoire une
partie il me semble de critchouk avec
les Noirs
je sais plus quoi qui avec les Blancs
est-ce que tu l'as sur chaise
vous avez jamais dans ma tête
[Musique]
tu vois
il a mangé des quatre
je reviens dans un instant surtout je
vais remplir ma bouteille d'eau vas-y
vas-y vas-y t'inquiète là je suis en
train de préparer les les
[Musique]
il commence déjà hein
il arrive mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu moins mon petit
chouchou
je trouve qu'il est monstrueux quoi et
c'est vraiment le joueur qui
m'impressionne le plus dans le circuit
alors quand je parle des nouveaux
joueurs c'est vraiment le joueur qui moi
maintenant le plus donc c'est le carpov
du 21e siècle tu es d'accord ou pas
carport
[Musique]
il est très concret qui calcule hyper
bien donc
carpov n'était pas qui calculait mal
mais c'est plutôt un style à la castor
j'avais envie de dire
je le vois plus dans ce style là je me
souviens pas de l'avoir vu sacrifier un
pion de toute sa vie quand même la Mino
dire bec pourtant j'ai regardé ses game
mais il est hyper concret de
olympiade il a été incroyable aussi
c'est lui qui a porté enfin pas tout
seul mais il a clairement fait des
grandes choses avec une toute petite
équipe de
toute petite équipe de 12 bakistan ils
nous ont tous fait rêver voilà si la
lastouffe c'est peut-être le finalement
le souffle du 21e siècle tout ça
quelle chance
et en fait ouais
ça on le voit un petit peu à ça à sa à
sa posture et à son et comment dire à
son
à son charisme tu peux le dire ouais en
fait tu sais quand tu joues il est
vraiment à fond dans la partie quand il
a une attitude
où là je suis rien rien rien et je
trouve que c'est juste enfin je sais pas
je trouve que il a un air implacable
aussi tu as l'impression qu'il va il
l'aura jamais enfin faudra vraiment que
tu sois incroyable quand est-ce qu'il a
perdu la dernière fois je vais regarder
les stats on va voir ce qu'on a je vais
aller voir la troisième partie pour voir
un petit peu ce que font les gens on n'a
pas vu encore mais bien Rohff n'a pas
encore vu tari
[Musique]
pour vous dire la dernière fête en
partie longue de nos diabète Abdou ça te
ref toute notre chouchou après il y en a
des parties d'un père il est encore
jeune il a 18 ans à peine mais il a une
progression vraiment tellement
impressionnante que c'est intéressant en
cette partie de ma médié on va pouvoir
la voir un peu le début ça commence par
une anglaise
et ça se transformer voilà
ou tiens ça c'est pour c'est pour route
dans le chat
et ouais dans le dans le dans un de mes
industries niveau absolument que le jour
et j'ai dit non
ça a été joué par Paris donc pas mal
alors là il a une position un peu
typique avec C4 un typique d'une sorte
de ninjo où en fait les Noirs vont
essayer de jouer avec leur majorité tu
vois ils ont ici quatre pions
hop contre 3 et le but des Noirs c'est
de pousser un peu ses pions là et te
créer sur long terme un pion passé
le plan des blancs généralement c'est
plus avec cavalier 2 pour jouer un pour
essayer de jouer avec E4
c'est plus dans le plan ou alors cette
cavalier 5 F4 un peu à l'ancienne mais
généralement quand même mais ça balancer
le cadre c'est un plan assez naturel ici
donc on va s'exprendre avec les noirs de
ce côté-là pendant que les blancs et ben
ils vont aller au centre donc c'est
chaud
et
j'aime bien cette position pour les
Noirs déjà je trouve que ça a l'air
agréable à jouer le tour B8 il est
évident c'est pour faire B5 en un seul
coup et tu auras 4 on pourra juste faire
B4 ça sera déjà mieux pour nous ouais
donc il y a pas de là si les si les
blancs font à 4 est-ce qu'on fait est-ce
qu'on fait à 6 on va vraiment
pas le droit de faire à 5 sinon jusqu'à
va le prendre
ah ouais c'est pas désagréable cette
position dis-moi pour les Noirs non mais
je vais réussir à avoir mon petit setup
en place après les blancs vont aussi
jouer sans batteur regarde il a jeu E4
direct
à tout de suite d'accord il a réagi
avant même que le noir arrive à jb5 donc
bah écoute voilà ma médias dans son
style et il est hyper concret mon avis
hyper concret donc là ben j'imagine
qu'il faut manger
surtout tes pions
par exemple là tu vois je me voyais je
me ferais mal je le fais aussi par
exemple
parce que je sais pas il y a du cavalier
G5 il y a plein de trucs je me dis bon
ça va pas l'air bon quoi
mais après la prise cavalier prend là il
faut voir un peu ce qu'on peut faire
peut-être que tu vois il y a cavalier
enfin en l'air en D4 il protéger deux
fois attaquer deux fois oups pardon
comme ça donc peut-être on peut imaginer
un fougère qui va éliminer un défenseur
pour aller manger
6 c'est un point isolé hein regardez
bloquer un peu la case il y a plein de
trucs intéressants je trouve que je
trouve que les
c'est plus intéressantes bah moi j'aime
bien les Noirs généralement cette
position
isolé donc le risque c'est que la
situation se clarifie très vite au
centre mais dans ce cas les pièces
peuvent se changer super vite qui ah oui
mais par exemple bah regarde rien que
que j'ai 4 là on peut imaginer que on va
échanger les deux pions etc quelques
pièces là et en fait au final
et c'est nul donc ça c'est bien sûr une
possibilité mais améliorer avec les
Blancs il joue contre Paris qui est le
moins fort du tournoi c'est un joueur
local
norvégien
je pense quand même pour gagner le
tournoi on a envie enfin devoir un petit
peu d'essayer de de battre ce type de
joueur mais tu arrives c'est pas un
clown non plus hein il a 26 50 solide
depuis maintenant plusieurs années il a
déjà démontré à maintes reprises qu'il
est capable de battre des joueurs du top
mondial donc il faut pas non plus le
prendre pour un débile si tu l'attaque
il va te répondre donc après ça reste
quand même le moins fort du circuit donc
c'est vrai que tu as les blancs contre
ce jour-là ont un a quand même envie de
d'essayer quoi donc ça c'est clair je
pense qu'il va pas se priver tu vois il
joue des coups de principe pour lui mais
pas selon l'ordinateur les blancs sont
déjà un peu moins bien ce qui est quand
même assez rare à ce niveau là au 13e au
12e
après c'est égal quoi ma mère s'en fout
non mais ma mère s'en fout c'est pas du
tout lui il veut une pause jouable il
veut que ça bouge un peu je pense pas
qu'il a envie de tout échanger
maintenant effectivement il va falloir
qu'il trouve un plan concret pour garder
du matériel
jouer sur les faiblesses noires
même si il sait que c'est pas forcément
beaucoup
d'échecouler son tendu
j'ai la stat amusante à propos de de
nous dire Beck à 120 qu'on cherchait
tout à l'heure sa dernière partie perdue
c'était pas contre Magnus c'était pas
contre Kawana c'était contre le jeune
Vincent kimer alors au Master de
Düsseldorf en février
donc en fait il a perdu contre un autre
jeune de son âge
pareil en pleine progression
qui était tout le temps là quand j'étais
avec avec Laurent donc salut à toi
bienvenue exactement
héritons 34 qui nous dit et c'est vrai
un jeu je le vois bien Kylie de faire 4
et ben il y a souvent des quatre en
l'air donc moi je ne suis plus dans
l'idée tu sais que je t'avais dit de
cette ninjo en fait toujours avec ce 4.3
et c'est position là qu'on joue
généralement avec ça et ça dans la
limite dans cette position il est pas en
C6 mais c'est vrai que dans cette
position je suis bien d'accord avec toi
rython c'est difficile de jouer avec le
4 si on joue le Caval en V2 donc
peut-être d'ailleurs pour cette raison
là entre autres que ma médié le 4 c'est
plus concret et puis et puis il a
compris que quatre seraient difficile à
jouer donc la balançait quoi donc je
trouve ça bien
je trouve ça bien
et je sais pas si ça fait chez vous
aussi mais chez moi ça me bug
enfin mon twitch à chaque fois ça me met
des écrans genre erreur je voir après
tout le temps passe ça le fait chez vous
aussi donc c'est que chez moi j'espère
que ça fait pas chez eux moi j'espère
que c'est moi le problème
pas très sympa qui nous dit que ma mère
a 50 ans je pense pas qu'il en est 40
pour voir 35 36
[Musique]
ouais je dirais 37
il va 38 cette année peut-être
il est passé vu que ça encore pas trop
après oui c'est un peu un papy par
rapport à la nouvelle génération ils ont
tous 18 ans Max bon bah oui la double
mais après il est pas vieux quoi je veux
dire ça va quoi puis ça reste et un des
tout plus dangereux du monde quand même
ah oui c'est clair
50 ans au niveau capillaire oui oui
bravo
alors est-ce que on passe voir la partie
la partie en quatre on n'a pas encore on
n'a pas encore regardé il s'agit de la
partie de Abdou contre Guiri bah oui
donc on va aller voir on fait que de
parler d'Abdou on va essayer de voir un
peu et oui c'est vrai que là mais
donc on est dans un candidat accepté
puis ils sont isolés encore comme tu
détestes et Abdou est en réflexion
depuis 19 minutes quand même 72e
après le petit le petit B6 de guéri qui
vient qui cache pas ses intentions qui
va développer son fou tu arrives à avoir
la partie ouais c'est bon tu l'as ouais
parce que ça m'a tout changé
et donc là il réfléchit plus 19 minutes
pour chercher son plan le jeune
et ouais alors on va voir plus le début
si vous voulez si vous le voulez bien ça
commence avec
6 C4 6
ou 7 ok donc c'est un combat
ou H4 des Français 4 avec
je sais plus je sais pas d'accord les
noms c'est pas toujours mon truc ok
mais pour c'est un ici et B6 a été joué
par par les Noirs donc B6 c'est un coup
assez standard sachant qu'on veut jouer
en fait contre le pion isolé à un plan
qu'on pourrait avoir avec le noir c'est
pas le cavalier à 5 le fameux cavalier
le cavalier mvl fameux pour jouer après
fou B7 et bien contrôlé la case D5
éventuellement plus tard un cavalier 5
une tour en C8 etc
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire dans les
positions où on a un pion isolé est-ce
que tu connais toi un petit peu les les
plans qu'on doit faire généralement avec
les blancs ou les Noirs contre un pion
je sais qu'on aime avoir un jeu de
pièces actif donc qui tourne autour du
pion isolé là globalement les pièces
mineures blanches ont l'air plutôt bonne
mais ce que je me demandais la très
concrètement c'est si on n'avait pas le
droit de faire descendre tout de suite
pour se débarrasser de cette faiblesse
alors ça j'imagine que c'est le coup qui
va faire nul direct ouais ouais bien sûr
mais est-ce qu'il a envie de jouer tu
vois je sais je sais pas oui je pense
lui il veut jouer
en fait alors
c'est assez tricky tu vois
si vous voulez si vous voulez
avec les Blancs c'est le joueur qui veut
moi qui veut gagner hein c'est le genre
de partie il veut gagner diri bon bah
c'est un joueur qui réplique très solide
je fais souvent des nuls mais c'est pas
parce qu'il fait des nuls qui jouent
forcément hyper net
sa chance il est mort tout de suite
ouais puis en plus il est mais en fait
il est il joue pour gagner en fait mais
après il fait souvent gagner et bon là
c'est vrai que dans cette position tu
dis bon nul avec les Noirs il va la
prendre direct parce que bah il a les
Noirs contre un très bon joueur vous
savez que au niveau l'objectif avec les
Noirs c'est d'arriver à égaliser donc
donc elle fait noir il va le prendre
donc les blancs doivent démontrer
quelque chose un petit peu voir s'il est
possible de faire un truc il est blanc
on doit baisser le jeu pour gagner
maintenant quand on joue avec un plan
isolé alors là c'est un peu de crédit
parce que
les blancs
le pion isolé c'est une faiblesse le
pion d'accord c'est une faiblesse donc
comme j'ai une faiblesse et ben il faut
que j'arrive à jouer de manière hyper
active pour
attaquer par exemple grâce à ce pion D4
quand même ben j'ai un point d'appui
éventuellement E5 je bloque un petit peu
depuis aussi tout ça et je contrôle le
temps
les Noirs d'un autre côté et ben il faut
qu'on les allait et le but des Noirs ça
va être de bloquer premièrement le pion
isolé donc soit baisser à 5 par exemple
donc il bloque le pion isolé et
éventuellement on peut aussi échanger
des pièces
ce pion sur le long terme sera toujours
fait moi il y a de pièces plus le
pneumon de 4 sera faible donc plus je
change de pièce mieux c'est pour les
Noirs
donc du coup bon les blancs vont
l'activité mais si jamais les blancs
n'arrivent pas à prouver vraiment
quelque chose et ben à ce moment-là et
ben le pion sera faible c'est pas si
simple de trouver de l'activité ici avec
les Blancs quand même parce que
tellement bien mise et ouais là on voit
qu'elle va aller au 5 sur ce coup-là il
y a des cartes qui va tomber j'ai pas
envie de le faire pièce noire sont hyper
solides il a aucune faiblesse avec les
Noirs la Mendès passe mais
et puis en plus il y a des pièces qui
peuvent facilement s'échanger rapidement
et donc à voir
ici je m'a parlé du coup de dessin tout
à l'heure
donc c'était l'impression avant à trois
mais ici ce coup D5 c'est un coup qui
permettrait d'échanger cette faiblesse
en dessin et une faiblesse mais qui peut
aussi être une force d'emploie de
pollution si jamais j'arrive à dynamique
et cette heure j'ai dit que ça allait
sûrement faire un nul donc j'ai pas
calcule du tout hein pareil l'idée comme
ça mais ça doit faire nul ouais
et si tu prends là je peux manger en
fait et on va cette position alors je
sais pas dans quel sens le faire
prononcer
à peu près égalité
et donc c'est possible peut-être de
perdre genre de choses mais
avec les blancs mais il veut mettre la
pression il veut gagner donc la raison
de jouer ça
et c'est vrai que si vous n'êtes pas
vraiment adepte un de ces parties depuis
on isolés on a toujours l'option à tout
moment de faire nul
dès que je
en fait au niveau au niveau structurel
pour ceux qui jouent la française côté
noir il y a une Française robinstein en
fait c'est exactement le classement
et sauf qu'en face les Blancs ont un
pion isolé donc c'est vraiment tout
bénef pour les Noirs c'est une bonne
très très bonne roue Einstein
mais après quand même c'est vrai que ce
pluriel c'est pas tout le temps une
faiblesse non plus
maintenant la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on joue avec les Noirs c'est
pas mal non plus
donc j'ai toujours ce coup qui qui
pourra jean-marcher pour faire nul si
jamais vraiment ça marche pas bien mais
sinon tu vois chez les Noirs la position
est extrêmement solide tout va bien
j'aimerais bien tu vas me dire si ça si
c'est bien de faire des 6 pour
cavale 7 et pour mettre un cavale en D5
[Musique]
il va casser ce plan ici
mais de toute façon ce fouet maintenant
il sert plus rien vu qu'il y a plus de
fois en h alors moi je préfère jouer
parce que c'est 8 moi j'aime bien le
coup Cavalaire à 5 déjà parce que j'ai
besoin de contrôler avec toutes mes
pièces cette case des 5 et en plus je
vais faire caler ces cadres qui va
attaquer les deux à trois et boucher un
peu ton fou ton fou ici
et je pense que c'est pas mal
éventuellement plus tard qu'elle valait
les dessins
qu'elle va les prendre enfin tu vois
vraiment je vais changer toutes les
pièces
change tout et j'aime bien ce coup comme
ça alors que vous décide ça m'a l'air un
petit peu longtemps
[Musique]
il a pas encore joué dans cette position
mais ça serait très guérie effectivement
la suite que tu viens de montrer ouais
bon c'est juste normal je pense mais
maintenant peut-être que je dois
empêcher qu'elle aille Seka donc
peut-être dame 2
mais bon F3 il y a quatre enfin
concrètement et quand même pas mal de
choses je suis pas sûr de vouloir donner
mon fou pour manger un pion un pion qui
était faible de base peut-être que plus
tard ben la part de fou blanche sera
plus forte que le pion sacrifié parce
que quand je donne des colonnes je donne
plein de choses
je suis pas sûr que dame
jusqu'à Lausanne aussi
une idée après Caval le 5 peut être
éventuellement de jouer
la diagonale du roi en fait
c'est un jeu c'est dalmique les noirs
sont très solides mais les Blancs ont
quand même plein d'idées d'attaque
regarde maintenant le jeu gagné 5 pour
changer les pièces très bien mais le
cavalier départ dame G4 d'un machin
peut devenir aussi un coup et en fait
c'est pas simple mais
les plantes
pour fixer le pion et qu'ils puissent
pas y avoir du G6 quand on ramène le
four en B1 en D3 après bon là je pense
que ça me fait G6 je vais faire cavalier
6 tu vas prendre aussi oui
aussi intéressant tu fixes ici H7 et gs7
qui aura plus jamais de G6 tout ça thème
cavalue 4 qui est clairement un coup qui
avait le cas d'un MG4 enfin écoute je
commence un peu à te poser des problèmes
pratiques
en fait tu vois c'est ça pion isolé tu
as un problème sur le long terme avec
ton petit pion mais
j'ai toujours du jeu à quatre pattes des
cases j'ai j'ai l'attaque là-bas j'ai la
barre de fou et puis j'ai un jeu plus
actif que toi donc maintenant c'est à
quel vraiment
à quel degré tu arrives vraiment à
t'activer par rapport à tampon qui est
faible tu vois c'est un petit peu
et peut-être que dans pas mal de
variantes s'il veut être offensif il
pourra laisser des quatre emprise quoi
ah oui par exemple on l'a vu même là
même là
je pense pas qu'il faut prendre beaucoup
je pense pas je te propose de même pas
aller voir ce contre Nakamura excuse-moi
vas-y
pour la fin parce que je sais que j'ai
vu j'ai vu le début et je connais les
joueurs c'est pas jojo ouais non mais
cette position elle est pas compliqué tu
as un pion moi avec les blancs mais tu
as tout sorti tu es prêt à attaquer et
là elle va où la dame déjà
un pion de récupérer fu F6 sont est-ce
qu'on prend à 7 il y a fou ces trois
quand même
je suis pas sûr ça me donne la part de
fou
certes mais c'est une manière de faire
vite fragiliser ta structure après oui
c'est peut-être un peu trop tôt
totalement une idée viable à un moment
donné si il faut le faire je pourrais le
faire quoi donc là on voit nos dire Beck
à jouer A3 que je vais fouger 3 en fait
qui resserre sa position comme un
ressort et elle va éclater plus tard en
fait
A3 je pense qu'à trois à me l'idée
c'était essayer de d'être cavaler B4 qui
a validé 5 était l'idée pour venir
bloquer son passé
d'ailleurs aussi qui avait les bécasses
fous acide
il y a plein d'idées de ce type là qui
sont thématiques et c'est qu'à 3 bah ça
empêche tout je joue quoi je joue un
truc
pour le pour le fou aussi
non ok bah c'est une partie intéressante
et on va voir un beau fight
on va quand même aller voir ma carte je
sais qu'on a pas trop envie mais enfin
il paraît que la partie elle est elle
est pas très excitante mais allons voir
un petit peu intéressant mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on l'a déjà vu beaucoup
de fois cette partie ouais alors attends
je vais juste changer le nom
c'est ultra théorique c'est une variante
de la Berlin avec le fameux coup tous
deux qui avait été inventé par Paco
Valero je crois le joueur espagnol je
sais pas si tu le connais toi qui est
qui vient d'Espagne
non mais
je me doute que tu le connais pas
mais
oui la 2700 hello c'était le numéro 1
espagnol en très longtemps plus de 2007
il avait inventé l'étrange coup 10 tours
2 enfin il avait inventé il avait été le
premier à le jouer et Carlson l'avait
joué en championnat du monde contre
carwana à New York
et ça avait fait un peu un tollé et en
fait Valero c'était empressé de Twitter
que c'était de lui
tu imagines bien
ok bon c'est une partie où il se passe
pas grand chose je sais pas ouf et on va
tout échanger mais bon
les joueurs américains qui connaissent
depuis toujours qui ont beaucoup
beaucoup joué ensemble
c'est les derbilles voilà je pense que
bon
ces deux joueurs très très très solide
aussi quand même en général
non mais ils ont tellement joué ensemble
on peut même dans les dans tous les
tournants internet
tous les trucs que tu peux imaginer
bon j'imagine que en fait peu a pas
envie de se prendre la tête je me
demande quand même pourquoi il a repris
du ouf en 8 là à l'instant après tout
reprend
pourquoi
une bonne remarque vraiment louche ce
coup
ça paraît tellement naturel de juste
reprendre de la tour et de s'activer
c'est de comprendre
il se dit qu'il y aura juste tous deux
j'imagine et c'est surtout ce qui avait
prévu
peut-être pas échanger les tours
il a un plan pour essayer de s'activer
de l'autre côté mais bon tu vois c'est
un peu difficile par exemple
B5 autour des cartes de partout et puis
est faible c'est imaginer un jour à 5 +
5 donc enfin ça m'a l'air bizarre mais
on se dit pour empêcher
je me dis bon tu as les Noirs tu
reprends alors juste tout à fait logique
avec fou B5 c'est d'aller manger
c'est une position à peu près égale mais
je t'avoue que j'ai du mal à comprendre
sans réfléchir
donc
voilà bon après on peut ils sont quand
même assez égal 2 de jouer je pense pas
trop s'attarder ça te dit on va partir
un peu chez cartel
je t'entends plus je crois que ton micro
désolé
j'étais en train de déterminer donc j'ai
coupé mon micro j'ai oublié de le
remettre alors il y a eu c'est prendre
des cas il y a eu c'est prendre des
cartes et maintenant Magnus qui fait
Damas 5 après une assez longue réflexion
en 18 minutes quand même et on est sur
le territoire d'une partie vallée
retiens encore lui et Daniel CEN avait
déjà joué ça ok intéressant
donc dans ma salle là j'imagine que je
suis en train de regarder les
différentes possibilités donc bien sûr
dames des deux bon il y a BK
[Musique]
qui peut être aussi bien sûr une idée
parce que développement après je mette
ma tour rapidement etc je suis fou des
deux et rock aussi c'est extrêmement
compliqué cette pollution il y a plein
de sacrifices possibles on va vous
montrer un peu les séries qui peuvent
éventuellement arriver alors en fait je
pensais à des choses du type rock
bonjaro que ça perd un plan je pense
parce que maintenant tout ça on en a
parlé du fameux sacrifice donc cavalière
il y a des vis-à-vis de partout donc là
tu pourrais plus faire pion prendre
malheureusement à cause de la perte du
cavalier ici
mais même si mais je défendais et ben il
y a plein de même de de
sacrifices à base de
f-13 aussi qui sont thématiques pour
gagner le champ des quatre donc par
exemple je sais pas moi si je joue un
coup du style A3 juste pour vous montrer
un petit peu pourquoi ici sur un coup
complètement regardable dans l'idée en
fait c'est qu'on va sacrifier une
qualité contre un contre cavalier là et
surtout prends et ben je vais manger en
de théâtre et en fait tout le centre des
blancs qui s'écroule et le roi est
encore au centre etc donc là cette
position elle serait évidemment très
difficile à jouer pour les blancs parce
que j'ai pas droit je suis très faible
de parcours et elle pue en prise mais
j'ai quand même manger une qualité donc
c'est compliqué c'est pas clair doit
être pas mal pas beaucoup de cases je
sais pas je peux venir ici j'ai pas
réussi à gagner le pur et 5
mais c'est vraiment ultra compliqué mais
en tout cas ça c'est le type de
sacrifice qui sont hyper thématiques et
d'ailleurs j'ai une partie en tête
j'arrive plus à me souvenir qui était
gris dessous qu'avec les avec les noirs
et actuellement je sais plus du tout que
c'était
il avait tout sacrifié
sur les pions du milieu sur
quelque part je sais plus si c'était une
qualité une tour ou un cavalier il y
avait eu des trucs qui s'étaient passés
et c'était une folie totale
imaginez cette position centrale sans
les deux pions blancs
on peut enlever une pièce au noir et
tout d'un coup tout d'un coup les deux
pions des Noirs ils veulent presque une
pièce en fait ils sont sans trop c'est
connecté
ça peut être un très intéressant
notamment dans des finales là il a
choisi de mettre le Caval en C3 donc
c'est une nouveauté la première
nouveauté de la partie OK
et donc oui non parce que c'est un jeu
dynamique et il va se passer quelque
chose là il va y avoir un vrai fight et
en plus dans le enfin si on regarde un
peu l'historique de carwana Cassen on
avait vu que dernièrement au speechers
et
après c'était rejouer il avait regagné
derrière enfin dernièrement car un scène
c'est vraiment le bourreau de carbonara
et très souvent quand il le battre sur
une tactique et c'est vrai que karmanin
[Musique]
et ben je le vois un petit peu un petit
peu fébrile
et du coup je pense que j'ai une
position très dynamique contre argent
comme ça enfin c'est pas mal
il va lui poser des problèmes parce que
il serait pas temps déjà de prendre 5 et
de lui demander comment comment tu
reprends
je sais pas comment on peut continuer il
y avait les bêtes qui se regardent aussi
mais bon je vais je vais me défendre
mais avec une menace discrète
il y a du B5 B4
je pense que la réaction des noirs
doivent être plus rapide et plus
centrale mais je sais pas je sais pas
peut-être cavaler même qu'avait les
bêtises
4 sachant que B3 a l'air difficile à
jouer il y a quand même
et la partie
de mémoire en fait c'est un truc qui me
dit quelque chose donc je peux pas te
dire maintenant ça fait il me semble
qu'avec les blancs c'est un chinois mais
je me trompe peut-être
mais c'est écrit chou qui je dirais
lui donner
2020 2019
c'est plus du tout
non je sais plus mais c'est une partie
que j'ai vu il y a quelques années et ça
me j'ai un gros souvenir de ça mais je
me trompe peut-être
et pour revenir à cette position ce que
j'aime pas du tout c'est la position du
roi blanc en fait parce que il est en
sécurité nulle part un peu
l'ouragan bah ouais le roi blanc si
jamais j'arrive à roquer faire un écoute
je suis pas mal hein ok ok mais je pense
la difficulté
alors pourtant je t'avais dit et après
je l'ai oublié tu sais qu'on a je
t'avais parlé hier
du fameux concessionnal oui et en fait
le professionnel
[Musique]
en fait si vous voulez c'est
un tournoi le permet et ben tu as une
salle de confessionnal c'est un peu
comme dans le story à l'époque en fait
c'est battu vas te confesser et dire un
peu ce que tu penses c'est ce que tu as
dans la tête et tu peux consulter la
salle quand tu veux même pendant une
partie d'échec et du coup tu as un
joueur qui peut très bien aller aux
toilettes
c'est un gros coup de patates d'accord
ok ce qu'il veut donc en fait c'est
intéressant et j'ai eu depuis le début
de vidéo professionnelles que j'ai pas
encore
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs non j'en ai pas deux
j'en ai 6
donc
[Musique]
c'est quoi
quasiment que des prêts game
ah d'accord d'accord
ils sont pas prêts cette histoire de
confessionnal là on l'a pas vu souvent
je me rappelle qu'il l'avait fait à
Saint-Louis Cup il y a quelques années
et c'était assez sympa ça nous avait
offert quelques moments assez mythiques
oups Carl scène notamment qui avait fait
comme ça c'était assez stylé
est-ce que je peux vous montrer si vous
voulez je peux vous montrer un petit peu
donc là on est là
un petit peu
[Musique]
les vidéos
parce que je les ai ici sont prêtes à
lancer je vais vous mettre la page
et il faut que je télécharge OK
attendez tout ça et à Magnus qui a joué
cavalier B6
depuis tout à l'heure il suivent quand
même plutôt nos coups donc je pense que
complètement attends j'ai perdu mon lien
je le refaire tout si vous voyez peu la
caméra d'Antoine c'est normal comme un
petit moment parce que je peux pas tout
faire ah ouais c'est toi qui me qui me
tu me cancelle donc là alors ce cavale
il arrive en C4 j'imagine
ce canal il arrive en C4 il va commencer
à poser des questions au fouet 3
peut-être option B2
et en fait tout d'un coup c'est des
Noirs qu'on le jeu là parce que le fou
de casse blanche il va enfin pouvoir se
développer via fouder 7 une petite tour
va pouvoir arriver en C8
et côté blanc on a plus trop l'idée on a
plus trop l'idée F5 qui viendrait je
crois qu'on l'a plus cette idée non
tactiquement ça marcherait pas
[Musique]
jouer F5 alors que je peux pas jouer F5
alors tout on s'en priver il est sous
pression
donc là les blancs peuvent plus trop
faire ça pour l'instant
attends je vais peut-être prendre toutes
les vidéos il me reste plus que deux
télécharger
[Musique]
je prends le pari et avec grand plaisir
j'ai pas dit de Somme je dis j'ai juste
dit je parie quoi
je parie aussi on a pas envie de ça on
n'a pas mis de Somme
Wanga enfin je sais plus peut-être
il faudrait voir en fait voilà partie
mais on va ouvrir tous
je suis un génie j'ai dit il avait les
Noirs pourquoi chinois en 2019 20 21
faut pas que tu crois que
[Rires]
j'ai dit
tu crois quoi on fait un semblant en
fait sur le stream
alors si vous voulez je peux vous mettre
la vidéo la vidéo je vous en mettre une
déjà pour aller
merci si vous voulez quand même gentil
je pourrais vous mettre les six
d'affilée bon c'est pas très long je
pense
c'est qu'on fait cela qui va qui ont
duré j'imagine combien ah je peux pas
mettre
à la fois malheureusement dommage on
commence par Paris si vous voulez
on va partir là dessus
on va voir ce que ça donne parce que
j'ai pas encore testé la scène
ça se passe bien
[Musique]
voilà j'ai pas écouté ouais j'ai ta
quête
pour ceux qui parlent pas anglais il
nous a dit que
il nous a dit que fouger 5 de mamène
n'avait pas tant impressionné qui
pensait que pour lui c'était assez
tranquille comme pose en fait il était
il sentait pas en difficulté OK
malheureusement j'ai pas
je vais terminer
je peux pas les voir moi et si je le
regarde en double je crois que vous
allez entendre en double
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qui était somme toute assez bateau
est-ce que c'était bien de prendre
Magnus le premier jour pour que quand il
est pas encore chaud et carwana comme
d'habitude à beauté en touche en
répondant bof voilà
je t'écoute traducteur
j'entends pas je sais pas si tu as
encore éternué que tu as oublié de
mettre le micro mais non c'est parce que
je regarde le stream mon Gers
donc la pression un peu donc nakan nous
disait il lui demande alors qu'est-ce
que tu penses il dit tout peut arriver
aujourd'hui tu parles lol nous on sait
très bien qui joue ceux qui vont faire
une turbo nul mais il a dit aussi que ce
time control donc cette cadence le
plaisait bien c'est ça lui plaisait de
jouer sans un crémant un peu et ça peut
faire des hypnotes assez amusant
c'est cool alors toutes ces confessions
elles peuvent être faites avant la
partie ou pendant la partie
[Musique]
ok donc cette fois c'était le beau
oriental qui nous disait que le style de
mamedia lui convient plutôt bien il a
réussi à le battre la dernière fois donc
il était très content parce qu'en plus
il sait que c'est un joueur entreprenant
d'ailleurs revoir un peu leur pause
après parce que ça chauffe un peu mais
voilà rien de Tarik avait l'air plutôt
confiance ok cool alors un quasiment
fini avec toutes ces interviews on va
voir l'adversaire
alors mamie c'est la grosse dépression
bien sûr
il part totalement perdant et dit j'ai
perdu contre tary l'année dernière il a
les chocottes globalement charriard
j'expliquais avec son d'air un peu blasé
mais à mon avis il en pense pas moins il
pense quand même qu'il va gagner par
exemple
OK et la dernière partie enfin dans la
partie dernier confession que j'ai c'est
une confession qui était faite pendant
la partie donc c'est hypero Nakamura
j'ai envie de prendre un pari sur ce qui
va lui dire oui je pense c'est turbo
drow écoutez là
[Musique]
qui nous a fait une petite pub inopinée
pour pour une marque de flotte et
qui nous a envoyé des variantes dans la
tronc des tours 2 des tours en voiture
voilà globalement il a dit qu'il était
bien content d'être là bien content
d'être ici
de jouer ce ce tournoi sans incrément ça
lui plaît beaucoup et il disait que
comme Wesley réfléchissait pas mal
c'était plutôt à son avantage même si on
sait tous ce qui va se passer dans cette
partie
alors qu'il se passe des trucs justement
beaucoup plus excitant je pense dans la
sur la première table
donc là il y avait plusieurs
possibilités donc tiens mon gf6 ok c'est
une décision à prendre mais d'un autre
côté c'est vrai que si tu manges pas moi
j'ai qu'est-ce 4 qui arrive surtout
qu'il y a des problèmes un peu dans
toute la position tu as du mal à croquer
il y a toujours des problèmes sur ton
centre ici
franchement c'est une position difficile
et pas forcément très agréable pour les
blancs cette pression constante sur tes
pions et des cases et donc il a essayé
de manger en M6 et souvent c'est une
très bonne réaction des blancs parce que
ça permet de pouvoir de gagner et
installer un cavalier en E5 et même
aussi tu vois depuis on le sait mais il
est arriéré un peu en retirer pour ceux
qui ne savent pas ce que c'est
c'est un peu qui se trouve sur une
colonne semi-ouverte donc là ici il est
blanc
et en fait bloc ce pion et ce pion en
Russie s'il est en arrière par rapport à
son copain d'accord et pourra jamais
avancer et pourra jamais être protégé
par notre pion voilà il est sur le code
mais c'est un peu toutes les tous
les conditions et plus tard sur le long
terme peut-être que si jamais j'arrive
je peux dire
[Musique]
éventuellement son H3 mettre un cavalier
le 5 bon je peux réussir à bien
consolider et attaquer sur le long terme
le pion E6 d'autant que c'est une
rupture qu'on a souvent dans la
française la rupture E5 sauf que la
fasse un pion D4 et un pion F4 elle
devient totalement impossible c'est ça
donc
intéressant mais après il va garder là
maintenant tu as le temps des 4 mine de
rien il est isolé
après c'est pas le même isolé que dans
la partie d'Abdou parce que là c'est un
plan isolé avec pas de pion en face
mais ce pion il est isolé parce qu'il
peut pas dépendu par l'entretien et tout
ça il a pas de pions
sur les colonnes adjacent là ici
et ce plan est faible je retente mais ce
plan quand même pas mal de cas donc
apparemment un plan qui est faible il
est pas trop hâte à câble mais on peut
quand même le dire donc quel peut être
un plan des Noirs j'aime beaucoup
attaque là
attends tu viens
à l'autre coup c'est que les deux coups
ont l'air pas mal
il y a aussi ce plan qui est très très
typique dans la française une fois que
l'option 1 va été bougé ramener le fou
sur une meilleure case en passant par là
donc on fait on fait un peu de Snake on
passe là-haut soit on va en H5 on mange
F3 mais généralement c'est pas terrible
d'abandonner ce fou c'est le pion aussi
ça va être faible
mais en tout cas être un coup plus tard
c'est sûr parce qu'on va mettre
et en B3 je suis pas fan d'un côté ça
mais d'un autre côté j'ai peur pour le
case noire mais comme le fou de case
noir des Noirs vient de partir en F6
peut-être qu'on peut se permettre de
jouer V3 mais visuellement ça m'a la
moche
c'est un gros affaiblissement quoi tout
simplement il y a cavale B4 qui arrive
tout de suite et attaque
c'est qu'il peut être intéressant avec
des menaces
ça c'est pas forcément bien après je
comprends bien
est-ce que je peux jouer ici un coup
comme cavalier le 5
est un coup peut-être mais bon c'est un
peu triste je pouvais pas à moins que tu
veuilles faire ça ça t'appellera dessus
qui va venir sur le long terme aussi
parce qu'en fait je me dis que ça ça ok
certes on va manger et bien c'est vrai
que plus tard le fameux fout de case
noir qui est mauvais dans la française
va se retrouver avec une très très belle
diagonale ouverte là c'est vrai donc si
jamais j'arrive pas à vite réagir avec
un dessin qu'un truc comme ça et ben ton
foutrant C4 sera pas valide
parce que la paire de fou va commencer à
parler là en plus
calculer toutes les variantes concrètes
et il a dit ça va je peux le faire
exactement je peux le faire il y a rien
là qui m'empêche tactiquement tu vois il
y a pas un taxi un truc qui m'empêche de
faire B3 bah c'est un coin intéressant
parce que Caval et C4 c'était quand même
l'idée principale de Magnus et le
cavalier B6 ma mine de rien bloque la
dame aussi donc j'ai un peu moins de
chance et si bah écoute
voilà il a calculé que ça va ben c'est
bon il a pas tant d'avenir il a pas de
temps de cases de rebond peut-être
qu'effectivement il faut faire du Fou 7
cavale des 7 cavale F6
pour recycler un peu toutes ces pièces
c'est un peu lent en fait le problème
c'est que j'ai l'impression que celui-là
j'ai pas envie de faire croire
ici
que ma position va être
avantageux.fr
j'ai l'impression que
cette position qui soit de long terme
peut être très bonne pour les noirs et
que les noirs doivent être très concrets
ici c'est mon impression
mais là je pensais à faux 7 pour jouer à
trois et aussi
mais après
et là c'est dur je sais pas trop où
aller pour ça il y a ça qui fait peur
sur ça il y a ça qui est un peu embêtant
aussi en fait à chaque fois il y a des
trucs il faut calculer de partout quoi
peut-être ça ça est un coup
et là mon fou lui il a un peu touriste
[Musique]
toujours une idée de ramener une tour en
C8 pour augmenter la pression
ouais ouais ça devient vraiment
intéressant dans ce cas là pour les
Noirs mais même si elle bleu qui parle
de ça ça j'avais même pas vu j'avais
donné la même bande que lui et qui avait
les biens
mais non mais en fait c'est tu vois si
ça marche pas pour les Noirs en fait les
blancs sont bien mais c'est vrai
la ressource de ciel bleu avec Caval B1
à la à la fin
qui est un peu enfermé à la fin des 7
normal on met la tour ici on prépare
aussi éventuellement un truc comme ça
donc ce coup de fou vite fou qu'on ne
verra pas parce qu'il y aura trop de
problèmes sur sur 6 rapidement ça peut
aller trop vite mais je pense que là
juste pour C8 et cavalier bouge pression
là et est assez
normal
pardon j'avais l'autre idée avec kdset
tout à l'heure aussi je pensais et
essayer de faire un truc comme ça et si
tu prends là je prends la
et j'arrive à débloquer un peu la
population et j'ai des cases pour mon
cavalier aussi mais bon c'est pas
vraiment ce que ça vaut par exemple même
je mange et tu as des pions mauvais donc
il y a plein d'idées mais bon si les
Noirs arrivent à stabiliser enfin si les
blancs se stabilise pour avantage
et en plus l'idée avec Roy F2 tout à
l'heure qui était pas bonne à cause de
l'ouverture possible de la colonne F là
maintenant le roi en F2 il paraît
totalement safe
effectivement alors Roy F2 ou
petit rock garrokan
si tu veux jouer au royaume 2 pour
tourner un pourquoi ne pas être petit
rock est tourné un
c'est pareil sauf que dans mon royaume
il est pas envisagé avec la tour
choisir je vais me ranger quand même
et petit rock pour Fabienne voilà donc
mon pronostic qui commence à être
complètement nul il est quasiment
impossible un autre coup c'est Magnus
qui va avoir
je commence à trembler ok est-ce que
vous voulez rapidement qu'on fasse un
petit un petit
[Musique]
résumé va voir un peu ce qui se passe
sur toutes les scènes regardez là
parce que si on fait une partie par une
partie ça va être un petit peu lent avec
cette scène vous avez accès à toutes les
parties directes donc on a partie de
carvana
contre goket
noir
mais après on pourra pas les cibler plus
facilement les parties ensemble
donc ce pion à trois noirs dans la
partie du milieu en haut qui est
toujours ici et qui pourra un jour
peut-être être capturé par les Blancs
tranquillement
mais tu vois que voilà les Noirs ont
réussi à faire des cinq le cavalier 3 un
peu comme on avait comme on avait un
petit IPS genre d'idée et il y a aussi
le plan détroit qui est aussi dans la
même colonne que la dame là haut et en
fait
de manière très active en fait tu vois
il commence à acheter ses cavaliers vers
l'avant elle va peut-être jouer du dames
2 des choses comme ça c'est tactiquement
c'est possible même
et a plus d'idées en fait avec son
cavalh 5 il veut empêcher les idées de
cavale F4 tout simplement ouais il
n'empêche cavalier 4 et il a d'un petit
peu arrivé ok pas mal ma média off
contre Paris alors on avait eu tout à
l'heure la pollution qui avait l'air
d'être pas trop mal pour les pour les
noirs on aimait bien et on avait
d'ailleurs dit que ce pion isolant des
quatre on peut mettre le fou devant et
ça commence ce qu'il fait donc là les
blancs peuvent très bien manger le foot
le cavalier ce qui enlève un fou c'est
que moi j'adore les fous mais là quand
même lui on échange des pièces plus et
puis isolé bah c'est faible comme tout à
l'heure et ben on voulait expliquer
quand vous avez un pion isolé gardez vos
pièces sinon votre pion il va être fait
tout le temps et vous allez le perdre
quoi donc gardez vos pièces et là j'aime
beaucoup la potion de taille je pense
que tu en penses en toi mais je l'aime
beaucoup ça se passe à merveille pour
lui là depuis le 4 et l'ouverture du
centre de là le foot casse blanche de
toute façon c'est vraiment pas grave je
pense de le perdre vu que le foot casse
blanche des blancs et dominait par les
pions de deldam et en fait ces pions de
l'eldame ils vont pousser il va y avoir
du A5 du B4 c'est un plan à long terme
mais qui va être fort et je vois pas où
est le compte je noire le blanc pardon
ouais j'aime bien les j'aime bien cette
position
bah après il y a encore plein de pièces
sur les chéquiers encore plein de choses
et
théoriquement quand même à dire
africaine plus fort que tu arrives donc
on va en passer mais pour l'instant
j'aime beaucoup la position de Ariane
après on a vu dans l'interview d'avant
partie que s'il y en avait un qui était
confiant c'était plutôt le jeune tarié
que ma mère avait l'air un peu boudeur
bah il a dit donc en fait tu sais quand
tu as déjà brisé la glace en fait tu as
peur quoi et tu vas et puis juste donc
c'est cool c'est un bel état d'esprit en
tout cas il est il est dernier tournoi
en terme d'élo Paris donc
lui il risque rien alors que
la pression de devoir gagner on a contre
un joueur qui est censé être moins fort
mais qu'il a déjà battu et qui est très
dangereux aussi en fait tu arrives très
solide et opportuniste donc
si tu envoies tout comme ma mère
en fait il peut tout simplement juste te
répondre gentiment voilà il y a pas
touche qui nous demande si c'est nouveau
de jouer sans incrément au nord-ouates
et moi j'aime bien c'est marrant donc je
rappelle la cadence c'est deux heures KO
et au 40e coup vous avez 10 secondes
d'incrément en fait
donc en fait c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant dans le sens où c'est pas
les cadences championnats du monde ils
sont 1h30 30 secondes par coup avec
une heure au 40e coups et une demi-heure
au 20e coup et avec fin bref on joue 7
heures
la scène partie ou normalement au bout
de
3h30 4h ces grosses avec notes et
c'est du Blist quoi donc en fait ça
mélange vraiment
le parti lente officiel etc avec des
cadences plus rapides et d'ailleurs en
cas de match nul et ben il y aura en
Armageddon en 7 minutes contre 10
donc c'est intéressant quoi moi je
trouve que c'est cool et c'est vrai que
le
l'entréement alors moi j'aime bien
l'incrément depuis que on utilise
maintenant quand même pas mal d'années
mais au début quand j'étais plus jeune
d'ailleurs même beaucoup de gens dans le
chat je pense même toi d'ailleurs
Antoine il y a peut-être non pas toi
j'ai commencé les échecs très tard ça
commence tard mais il y a beaucoup de
gens peut-être qui ont qui ont appris à
jour d'échec avec à l'époque les
cadences qui étaient
normales ko quoi et moi j'ai appris le
Fisher c'était une env isageable on
l'avait jamais joué
les pendules mécaniques quoi donc
électronique c'était pas forcément
obligatoire tu vois donc tu joues tu
jouais à l'époque en 2h40 trous et 1h15
et après beaucoup pour la qualité du jeu
les incréments la cadence Fisher non bah
en fait quand tu as une pendule
mécanique le problème c'est que tu vas
pas bien combien de temps tu vois tu
peux avoir 30 secondes à la pendule mais
tu sais pas si tu en as 30 on a deux ou
10 enfin c'est compliqué et c'est vrai
que bon
à faire et ton drapeau qui est comme ça
et qui va tomber tu sais pas combien de
temps tu vois et c'est vrai que c'est un
plus vachement alors que là une
stratégie tu dis bon ok je suis mal
autant mais comme je sais que j'oublie
ce bien tu as mis alsaharine combien de
fois dans cette partie il a 30 secondes
contre une heure à pas une heure mais
j'avais pas pris une partie qui arrive
contre Prague il y a pas longtemps pour
ton argent
il avait 30 secondes contre 40 minutes
comme ça
et potion de ouf très compliqué et bah
il a fait nul tu vois mais en fait en 40
coups dans le chaos c'est compliqué de
faire l'équilibriste tu vois tu veux pas
tu es pas sûr de tout ça quoi donc après
c'est un temps c'était longtemps
maintenant on est habitué au
Richard et c'est vrai que bon bah quand
je dis Fisher c'est c'est les cadences
avec un crémant et
maintenant moi j'aurais du mal à jouer
en chaos parce que je suis trop habitué
avec la caméra mais après bon s'il faut
je le fais mais voilà dans tous les cas
c'est marrant de retrouver maintenant en
2023 quand même un tournoi avec ko quoi
ça marrant quoi
le championnat du monde était encore en
chaos il y a pas si longtemps il me
semble genre
[Musique]
mais là ils ont de l'incrément il faut
le préciser quand même après le 40e coup
oui mais là c'est deux heures KO et au
40e coup on rajoute
et si on continue notre petite tour des
stades il y a la partie entre nous dire
Becks à torov et Annie Giri au quatrième
échiquier et on avait évoqué
qu'effectivement les blancs pouvaient
juste pousser des seins qui est rentré
dans une talent très très égale mais il
a choisi d'appliquer tranquillement de
rajouter de la pression et la mille fois
G3 il a fait à 3 il a mis son cavalier
en E5 ça on s'y attendait Kiri a bien
mille fois en D6 comme je pense à tout à
l'heure et là le dernier coup de me dire
Beck c'est fou B5
il met la pression sur le cavalier que
les Noirs peut-être mangent en E5 ce qui
ne sera pas le cas non on peut imaginer
cavalier à 5
mais cavaluation
[Musique]
suffisamment de fois alors on va
regarder alors parce qu'ici en fait
ce qu'on peut faire aussi une idée
peut-être il y a dans ma 4 qui peut
arriver merci l'idée c'est d'attaquer
vraiment ce cavalier avec plein de
pièces quoi et forcer un jour une prise
enceinte parce que les Blancs cherchera
à avoir vraiment offrir la position et
la question que je me pose c'est sur un
damacade qui a l'allié à 5 parce que
j'ai pas du B4
qui avait quand même bien perdue
donc
après je peux venir en dessin comment
être 5 mais bon attention j'ai à ce
temps là
de suite peut-être
[Musique]
mais ça a pas l'air de marcher ça c'est
l'idée dont je parlais tout à l'heure
je prends là et bah écoute je gagne la
part de fou et je suis assez content
à la bonne heure
c'est 6 quand même et ouais ouais non
c'est mieux pour toi c'est sûr
ouais je sais pas comment je dois jouer
là
c'est un truc ça ça
fonctionne
et du coup sur cavalier 17 je pensais
pas mais attention
c'est une décision assez assez compliqué
mais bon ça peut être des choses qui
sont enfin ça peut être joué par par
Abdou parce que bah écoute on a réussi à
gagner l'ouverture du roi noir après on
l'a expliqué l'autre jour en stream je
peux je devais être à dernière journée
de stream de champions je suis avec
Fabien leski et on parlait du fait que
le roi ici avec les pions ouverts c'est
pas toujours un roi qui est faible et
que si jamais j'arrive à défendre ma
structure ben ça va par exemple si je
peux je crois
que ça par exemple mon roi est très bien
si jamais il y a pas de pièces qui
arrivent à mater par exemple là les
cases noires sont ouvertes autour de mon
roi mais les Blancs n'ont pas de case
noir
déjà on voit que mon roi il est quand
même assez safe pour attaquer après que
je fasse ça ça bah t'as pas le cavalier
qui va venir en H5 embêter ou quoi enfin
tu vois les noirs sont quand même pas
mal et puis aussi mine de rien j'ai
aussi une tour angélique qui pourrait un
jour arriver aussi taper sur le plongée
donc
où ils sont qui en tout cas
et intéresse dans cette position
j'aimerais reprendre de manière assez
peu conventionnelle du pion F à la fin
de la vente que tu as montré alors
peut-être
après toute cette série d'échanges là
alors généralement F c'est pas
recommandé non non mais des fois pour
ouvrir la tour ça peut l'être là j'aime
bien le coup F5 pour essayer de fermer
ton fou qui va sûrement un jour revenir
ça diagonale là et c'est notre permet un
peu tout ça mais maintenant je dois F5
je me dis que est-ce que je peux avoir
une rupture pour ouvrir la position et
là je pense au coup je vais perdre et je
me dis que bon
premier aussi théâtre je pense
ça va pas le faire
il faut mais tu vois là on voit des
données intéressantes et français c'est
peut-être un très bon coup donc
normalement c'est pas super on mange
toujours vers l'intérieur avec vos pions
pour
parce que là si on fait froid mal puis
etc en finale c'est pas bon mais après
concrètement si jamais j'arrive vraiment
à activer tout rapidement ça peut être
pas mal ouais c'est une activation
gratuite de la tour il faut juste que
tactiquement ça soit pas réfuter dans
les cookies mais ça amusant c'est ça
sinon on avait alors pour terminer non
je pense qu'on va se passer peut-être de
regarder la partie sonaka
je pense j'ai du mal à présent la plus
intéressante c'est toujours Fabiano
contre Magnus on dit c'est passé après
B3 c'est fou d'essai
et Magnus a ramené une tour en C8 de
manière ultra logique pour jouer sur le
clouage sur la colonne C
Fabiano a décidé de mettre alors
peut-être pas le plus précis il a choisi
Dame des deux l'ordinateur conseiller
plutôt dame E1
ordinateurs
cette possibilité et taper sur un 6 mais
bon après c'est un peu chipoter quoi
c'est chipoter mais bon il y a un
problème quand même sur le Kamel C3 donc
il faut y répondre
pour justement
et on pensait aussi tout à l'heure cette
idée là j'ai une idée intéressante je
sais pas si j'ai envie de le faire
est-ce que je le montre est-ce que je
souffle
très vite à mon avis je pensais à 3
en fait parce que
je considère que toutes ces pièces
quoi ça c'est bizarre et je bon B4 c'est
aussi une menace qui gagne une pièce
oui
pas des moindres
et pour là et c'est très chaud ça fait
quand une vraie menace ça empêche aussi
fou B4 qui avait les Vegas maintenant si
vous calculez c'est ça
et bon
je pensais au début
d'Amadou il y a dame français 3 ok ok
faut regarder un peu peut-être
intermédiaires
en fait mon idée c'était que si il mange
là
je mange et après je prends la
ok le problème c'est que bon là par
blague
et là je pense que j'ai pas fait une
bonne opération avec
avec les Blancs je m'en fous dégueulasse
en E3 les 15 branches tout ouvert donc
cavalier B4 je rentre là je m'en fous là
bon ça va être l'ouverture de la fête
hein
en tout cas la menace elle est claire
immédiate c'est
avec ce coup à trois
donc
en fait bouger le Caval B ah toi tu
penses vraiment que tu prends à trois
réfute
avec un mais en fait dans ma tête quand
je quand j'allais te proposer à toi dans
ma tête je pensais avoir qu'elle allait
bien
et gagner partout mais j'ai oublié
d'apprendre les deux donc maintenant que
je vous dis ça et je vois que la chose a
pas bougé je me dis peut-être que
c'est bien chaud en fait et du coup je
te comprends un peu ce qui se passe
à travers
[Musique]
mais au pire même positionnement tu
avais l'autre en fait bon ça va pas du
tout qu'elle prend des cinq ça c'est
clair
mais
si ça marche ça peut être pas mal mais
il faut trouver l'idée derrière
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr mais
voir si la dame
mais bon je me présente quand même que
j'arrive à partir quoi
réussir un jeu trouber quoi un coup je
crois que c'est un coup illégal c'est
illégal et globalement non mais j'ai
l'impression quoi c'est de manière assez
incroyable les noirs peuvent se
permettre de se mettre dans le clouage
et de prendre à trois
et je le dis parce que j'ai vérifié que
l'ordinateur qui confirme
moi ce qui me confirme mais après
pour savoir il dit zéro et la ligne la
ligne
après donc à trois
il propose tout rêve B1
déjà mais bon dame c'est deux pour
déclouer le cavale peut-être menace du
Caval Bay 1
mais là il y a Caval B4
avec tempo
donc tout rêve bien je sais même pas ce
que ça fait en fait c'est juste avantage
noir il fait froid
c'est des varans d'ordi c'est pas très
simple à suivre ni à comprendre ok ok ok
bon en tout cas c'est une idée qui
aurait pu être intéressantes
malheureusement ça sera pas joué mais
c'est une idée très humaine donc karwana
aussi fort qu'il soit il peut penser à
trois je pense mais je pense qu'il va
avoir un trois coup franc il va il va
pas voir de suite il va pas oui oui tout
à fait mais bon moi j'ai pris le pot de
calcul pour savoir qu'elle va être bien
donc c'est pour ça que j'en parle sinon
non je suis pas donc voilà sinon à part
à part à trois qui n'est pas jouable
c'est intéressant parce que là
concrètement ma menace imaginons je fais
un chien juste pour voir un peu ce que
je menace je pense que j'ai trouvé
je crois que je gagne
parce que le couteau
C2 qui avait les bécane
[Musique]
mais bon je crois que c'est une qualité
il va faire ça
[Musique]
je peux pas vous dire
il y avait pas mieux pour se défendre
l'autre tour en séance à changer rien si
tu mettais la Tour Eiffel
moi je veux la même
avec mon cavale
malheureusement
et me dire que maintenant mon fou entre
la cassé un donc on pourra plus jamais
prendre la colonne toi-même et après je
vais rentrer et cetera
mais bon ça a pas l'air génial tout ça
et Lucas va les prendre avec quoi je
crois il y a plein de trucs qui vont
arriver
toujours un peu
mais le plus simple justement
c'est compliqué
d'être dérange des deux côtés chaque
joueur a ses avantages et ses
inconvénients dans la position une
position qui se trouve est extrêmement
compliqué ouais elle est très riche
chacun a ses forces et ses faiblesses
dans la pose à un moment le Caval S3
bien finir par arriver en E5 c'est une
fatalité du coup est-ce qu'il faut
bouger le Caval B6 on aimerait bien le
faire mais faut quand même qui protège
le foot des 7 à moyen terme
que faire avec les Blancs et un clouage
un peu chiant et attention ils ont déjà
18 coups enfin selon 18 coups et il
reste 52 minutes pour les blancs et 1h03
pour la noire je me rappelle c'est du
chaos jusqu'au 40e coup donc là il faut
savoir qu'ils ont encore 22 coups à
jouer et plus que 52 minutes à la
pendule pour carvana qui en plus là
c'est un moment assez critique dans la
partie où
je pense à tout se jouer
vraiment à ce qu'il va réussir
ou est-ce que Carlsen il va réussir à
vraiment
ils enchaînent les longues réflexions là
ça fait 9 minutes pour kerwana déjà sur
ce coup ce qui est quand même assez long
s
12 après fou C4 et qui a le 7 ok on
s'arrête
comme on l'avait envisagé il est pas du
tout allait chercher le pion à 3 et
c'est dit ça tombe là quand ça tombera
il a continué à s'activer sur l'aile sur
les lois avec un G3
il a réussi à redescendre cette position
est plus ou moins parler en tout cas de
ce type de position qui Siri qui avait
de grandes chances de d'arriver
et après cavalage 5 pouces et 7 T4 c'est
le coup qui était joué donc typique dans
le dans les positions de italienne et
d'espagnol un peu d'ouvrir la colonne E
et la diagonale blanche aussi un coup
tout à fait normal
qu'elle va le prendre des quatre ça rate
la tactique vous prend H6
OK
[Musique]
alors prise C3 peut-être ah tu me
laisses G27 pardon
c'est deux peut-être c'est chaud
et là en fait je me lasse peut-être du
non pas du dames c'est trop
c'est mon rêve mais je pense pas que ça
va marcher malheureusement
je voulais le faire avec du Fou prend
aussi c'est des maths en G7 mais ça
marche comme ça
un peu dans le même style avec un
sacrifice de dame là-haut
là on ne peut pas le faire le roi Arthur
la caisse de fuite H7 ça marche pas en
fin de variante maintenant ici tu prends
il y a ça en l'air donc
là je prends ici ce puis j'ai 6 et on
est très très bien ouais non c'est c'est
compliqué hein
par les deux joueurs je pense parce que
Lucas il aurait pas joué me prends des
cartes s'il avait vu il faut prendre H6
et
qu'à jouer son coup en 26 secondes son
cavale prend des quatre donc il a pas
cherché le radar était pas encore activé
côté français
ça aurait pu être rideau déjà au bout
d'un coup donc 3 de jouer bon il y avait
la petite menace de Cannes presque matin
H2
il a mis la tour au centre c'est logique
et on en met ici
donc 53 minutes avec les Blancs pour Ali
resa pour 58 pour goûtech dans une
partie qui est qui est très très
compliqué les Noirs
d'espace avec leurs pièces là et en
pions
un peu de peine qui va peut-être un jour
être mangé
par contre ce pion il sera mangé
vraiment je pense en fin de partie si il
est mangé parce que tu imagines que la
pour l'instant c'est joindre
à 3 j'aurai le temps de monter ma tac
avec plein de choses très rapidement
quoi
et d'ailleurs il y a même une tactique
peut-être qui marche très bien ce qui
est pas V4 avec un cavalier qui peut
être aussi en prise pour pouvoir un peu
tout ça mais il y a pas mal de tactiques
des deux côtés c'est vraiment le thème
de cette partie c'est le pion des trois
est très faible elle va tomber un jour
mais on n'a jamais le temps car
l'attaque noire arrive trop vite
donc là globalement qu'elle va le B4
devrait menace
on a le droit de prendre aussi ça
j'aime beaucoup manger aussi
généralement parce que ça casse la
structure mais d'un côté ça ouvre aussi
la tour mais bon ça ouvre ça ça voit ça
aussi
on doit regarder ça peut faire très mal
et cabane je veux
on sent quand même que là je peux
ramener des pièces
quelque part et doubler la colonne il y
a plein d'idées qui sont intéressantes
en tout cas
pour les joueurs j'aime beaucoup ces
positions
c'est un grand facteur les deux joueurs
c'est toujours de la nouvelle génération
firounja qui a 18 ans et 2785 vélos et
qui vient d'avoir 17 ans qui a 2532
hello c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
[Musique]
de grandes promesses ouais c'est ce
qu'on appelle des jeunes loups quoi très
ambitieux des vrais arcs qui vont dans
les années à venir trust c'était les
meilleures places à haut niveau on parle
peut-être de futurs champions du monde
avec ces deux là clairement
probable et les deux joueurs et ben ils
veulent se ils veulent se battre
mutuellement il y a pas de
il y a pas d'animosité ou quoi que ce
soit les joueurs veulent gagner les deux
joueurs donc ça montre un petit peu
l'ambition des Noirs quand il a joué à 5
à 4 à 3 et aussi à lireza qui joue au
centre une partie vraiment où ils
veulent se mettre sur la gueule quoi
donc
donc voilà la presque 20 ans a autant
pour moi floqué faut que je me renseigne
un peu plus sur son âge j'étais sûr
qu'il était de la manière
il est pas de l'amené de
2003 je crois 2004 elle est hasard je
vais juste regarder parce que je
je veux
sur apprendre
j'étais sûr que la manette
sur mon téléphone
le moins c'était pas important
il est né le 18 juin même si tu veux
savoir
et il est où notre ami
2004 je connais pas la date exacte je
peux 18 pareil mais septembre
d'accord 2004 ok
les enfants des enfants mon cher stouf
tout simplement ils sont jeunes encore
hier
donc c'est sympa en tout cas voir ça
doit génération qui arrive et qui
et qui en plus fait ses preuves vraiment
contre tous ces joueurs et c'est avant
hyper intéressant moi je suis trop
content de voir des nouveaux tournois
avec tous les joueurs bon ben star de
toujours tu as les Caravana les
caractères
Nakamura Guiri tu vois avec une nouvelle
génération de joueurs comme là on a
Abdou on a
firu on a coupé
plein de joueurs il manque un gazé il
manque prendre un lambda il manque gamer
il manque plein de monde mais vraiment
une nouvelle génération qui arrive et
qui et qui qui en plus à chaque fois
chaque tournoi fait des perfs et
progresses et donc on parle très
sûrement ici de comme tu dis tout à
l'heure de d'éventuels futures champion
du monde on pourrait mettre si Penko
dans le Lot même si on le voit moins de
depuis les événements en Ukraine on voit
moins les joueurs russes en général là
par exemple on voit qu'il y a aucun
joueur russe qui a été invité
assez logique que les Scandinaves
ont été très opposés à ce qui s'est
passé en ce qui se passe en Ukraine donc
les joueurs russes jouent beaucoup moins
mais si Penko Alexia and Co ses mecs là
ils vont sans doute
aussi faire partie des joueurs sur
lesquels il faudra compter mais c'est
incroyable la variante regardons nos
diabète contre Aniche incroyable c'est
exactement ce que tu disais
c'est la carte excuse-moi
aujourd'hui hein
totalement présent alors il y a eu il y
a eu d'abord un coup de fou B8 ce qu'on
n'avait pas forcément envisagé ok alors
ça par contre c'est pas c'était pas dans
la même reine dans le même esprit moi ce
que je voulais sortir
en attaque là là on met la pression et
cavaliers
alors on prend un peu ce qui se passe il
y a ça en l'air
voilà il
prend ici et je mange là mais je peux
aussi manger là
c'est intéressant peut-être que
cabaler prend est forcé
et maintenant je mange de quoi si je
mange là tu peux peut-être manger là
mais je mange s'il te plaît parce que
moi je vois un peu en retard du coup je
comprends pourquoi tu regardes pas le
mythe
le mythe que tu me fais il a juste
quelques secondes
parce que là si je fais ce qu'on essaie
tu vas prendre j'ai trois et je prends
là et je supprime une qualité donc ça va
pour les blancs j'ai l'impression
et
si je prends là et ben il faut que tu
mouches la tour
et pas de place en fait la pas de case
c'est une case en fait
mais il y a toujours ce plan isolé et
des pièces qui s'échangent donc malgré
tout si jamais
je prends la qualité mais j'arrive
toujours à avoir des bonnes pièces
mauvaises pièces toujours créé sur case
blanche un contre jeu mais bon je pense
quand même à bien aimer
alors ce que je fais ici
toujours bien agréable de gagner une
qualité
surtout en force comme ça
c'est un livre qui vient de se lever
pour enlever ça veste
classique à niche il baisse la veste ça
y est
ok intéressant en tout cas on en avait
parlées derrière
j'espère pour lui
[Musique]
après c'est pas pareil on va comparer ce
qui s'est passé
bon après il a des propres du monde
peut être je pense surtout qu'il faut
accepter à tout un système quoi bah oui
mais là après bon je suis bien d'accord
que c'est pas la faute des joueurs
sont pour rien mais
bon après
[Musique]
un poétique c'est compliqué tout ça
laisse moi des parties bon on a qu'à moi
je propose de ne pas y aller en fait
les deux Américains aujourd'hui mais bon
il mérite en fait absolument rien donc
on peut aller voir si tu veux peut-être
ma mère tari je suis d'accord parce que
ça posait vraiment intéressant
tout à l'heure au début et on s'est
arrêté après
c'est ça
qu'on avait dit que on aurait voulu
vraiment j'aurais voulu le manger bon je
sais pas calculer je suis pas rentré
dans tous ces trucs mais ça me
paraissait logique de faire ça avec deux
idées sur la première c'est pas fou
aussi pour bloquer vraiment la case des
5 pour
échangez là et manger des quatre qui
était pas forcément facile à faire pour
qu'on puisse
en C4 il y a plein de trucs calculés et
peut-être que c'était pas forcément le
bon choix ici là je vais P5 qui est en
fait après
infection à extrêmement normale la prise
en dessin qui va je fais qu'elle va les
prendre et j'arrive à avoir mon blocus
que je voulais sur le pion isolé des
quatre
cinq à l'art trop trop passif je pense
que BK j'arrive trop vite et en plus
j'ai des cases blanches donc ça a pas
l'air génial du tout pour les blancs je
perds trop de temps à faire votre 5 au 4
tu vois
donc il a joué ici le coup Dame des deux
en fait si c'est un peu une partie de
poker menteur là qui va faire tomber la
pression en premier c'est finalement
c'est le norvégien qui craque enfin qui
craque entre guillemets
C5 quand même aux Caval adverse il la
prend pas il la prend pas ma mère il se
dit qu'elle est
bah il y a ça
il faut calculer
alors pas tout de suite mais peut-être
que son cavaliers elle a besoin de
contrôler ces cases là
il a l'air beau mais il fait rien j'ai
l'impression quand c'est trois il est
sujet à se perdre des tempos avec B4
après je
je dis ça de manière assez schématique
mais non
c'est 5
menace
la soupe
peut-être que c'est suffisant
un peu aux fraises
ok je sais pas ça a l'air en tout cas
intéressant et là dans la partie qui
avait laissé trois mais je me dis bon
moi je prends ton case blanche et
peut-être qu'un jour je pourrais te
mettre mon coup sur le case blanche et
ça pourra éventuellement jouer contre le
pion je peux potentiellement perdre tu
vois comme les quatre planches étaient
ouvertes
avec ça
peut-être pas de pièce
et un peu plus donc c'est clairement
bien pour les noirs
donc quel est le 5 a eu le tour des 8 ou
F3
comme on avait un peu
dit sur dessin cavaliers B4
1 2 3 pour le cavalier et ce pion qui va
toujours être une faiblesse
écoute
j'aime beaucoup les Noirs c'est pas la
première fois que je le dis dans la
partie mais
c'est vrai que leur position elle a
beaucoup plus simple à jouer je vois pas
les plans blancs
c'est une menace avant ou pas ou pas ou
pas ou pas est-ce que c'est possible
on peut juste prendre le pion commencer
d'ailleurs je dis ça mais je vais
peut-être même encore mieux
je pense que ça
que ça fait
là c'est chaud mais bon peut-être que tu
aurais 8
c'est compliqué vraiment
alors dit qu'il propose dans cette
position de jouer B3 pour miner tout de
suite
les pions avancés des Noirs
parce que comme une de mes idées c'est
pas cavalier de Détroit
là au moins tu commences à miner alors
ça j'étais du camion
avec les deux prises C4 et ça récupère
je l'ai mis le défenseur et puis on l'a
qui défend lui et en fait après je fais
ça hop pour cette
double attaque ça marche
et une ligne après bon peut-être qu'il y
a mieux mais
ouais B3 ça fait vachement sens en fait
au vu du plan des noix mais bon c'est
pas évident
[Musique]
qu'un jour ils auront à 5 à 4 et un pion
passé
maintenant parce que j'ai plus l'appui
du cavalier là et ce pion est un peu
faible sur du cavalier 4 comme ça alors
on en a parlé avec tout roumain ce pion
qui peut avancer aussi quand même si
jamais j'arrive à pousser le pion
j'ai aussi éventuellement comme tu as
fait B5
qui pourrait être un jour peut-être
être prenable donc là pour l'instant
c'est pas possible mais peut-être que
après
je pourrais accéder cette case là avec
un cavalier en tous les cas je j'aime
beaucoup B3 et je pense
j'aurais envie de dire que on laisse
comme ça on touche pas parce que j'ai
vraiment envie de garder cette case pour
ma caméra
donc hyper intéressant comme ça
j'ai l'impression
donc tout se passer alors que Tariq que
40 minutes à la pendule je vous rappelle
pourquoi je m'inquiète parce que c'est
lui KO
c'est du chaos et que
ouais alors il veut changer des pièces
il attaque là et là
ça risque de forcer un cavaler prendre
des cartes tout ça
et sur cavaler prend des cartes
d'apprendre des cartes ça
bon maman ma première idée a été de
jouer cavaler C6 mais c'est parce que
je sais pas pourquoi
c'est une technique une tactique et puis
de mazette
mais bon tout ça pour finalement bouger
la dame et après remettre le cavalier en
e5d3 donc pourquoi ne pas directement
l'un des trois n'est-ce pas
comme disait mon tout premier entraîneur
un grand maître bulgare une fois j'avais
une super tactique en 5 et à la fin ça
faisait égalité matérielle pas davantage
et il m'a fait
très jolie mais à quoi ça sert et
et ça m'a marqué un peu maintenant
j'essaie toujours de penser à ça
sert quoi
si tu si tu prends un gros risque avec
une grosse tactique pour avoir une
potion égale
peut-être que tu peux faire mieux oui
[Musique]
et finalement ce cavalie passe est
stable
D3 pas tout de suite on va dire est-ce
qu'on peut jouer avec du à 5 à 5 pour
faire ton idée Caval C6 suivi de B4
alors un mélange je suis pas totalement
fan pourquoi parce que
comme un jour j'ai peur que ma structure
soit un peu cassée
donc
une fois qu'on a 5 oui mais il va bouger
la dame en fait dans le sens que si tu
fais ça sans
B4 je mange
c'est pour ça que
comme je tout casser j'en peux peur
qu'un 5 soit un coup a fait bizarre sur
le long terme je pensais à 6 et même au
pire faire ça ça et puis bon
ça pour rigoler mais en fait peut-être
pas si mal de réactiver s'il va pas en
Détroit puisqu'on a vu qu'en D3 il se
faisait tout de suite B3
en fait je me dis que ce cavalier il est
pas attaqué pour l'instant donc pourquoi
et puis si elle a bougé
de suite je sais pas
mais non moi je vais mettre un petit A6
et il a joué il a joué à 6 génie ouais
en fait c'est plus solide c'est plus
solide et je me dis que je suis comme B3
je peux même manger au pire des cas et
je garde mon de contraint et tranquille
ne presse pas à jouer à 5 et
me faire des faiblesses tout seul quoi
il prend son temps et prend son temps
dans cette pause le norvégien et il y a
un autre norvégien qui est un peu moins
bien dans sa position je vais aller voir
ce qui se passe l'ex champion du monde
magique et j'aimerais bien qu'on voit
ouais bah il y a eu cavale 2 on en
parlait tout à l'heure
on avait du mal à trouver une suite
cohérente pour clarwana il a choisi la
plus évidente je pense cavalier E2
laissant l'échange des dames les amendes
donc été échangés
et car celle qui dit maintenant je vais
doubler sur la colonne C
ce à quoi
qui sera prêt à la contester mais une
tour en C1 c'est tout à fait logique et
sur foie dessus tu auras tous ces deux
et cavaliers P4 est cloué pour l'instant
tu peux pas la
le bouger donc c'est ce qu'ils ont un
peu sur ça de torcer vite pour je
cavaler B4 aurait une bonne idée est-ce
que j'ai un fou c'est un qui peut
arriver
mais si tu refuses salut rayé nous salut
à tous
salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent on
est sur le nord-ouest première ronde et
là on est sur la table 1 Carlsen karuana
ouais alors si parmi vous dont on le
chat vous avez des questions quoi que ce
soit surtout n'hésitez pas en tout cas à
nous à nous écrire sur le chat on
essaiera de de vous répondre au mieux
si vous avez la moindre question dans le
doute ou quoi que ce soit en tout cas
n'hésitez pas
et même juste pour me dire bonjour aussi
c'est sympa aussi
vous êtes là
qui posent des questions qui fâchent
tout va bien
c'est tout va bien et bien le 16 juin
voilà oh la vache ça annonce des dates
et tout bah oui parce que je suis
actuellement à 2399
avec toutes mes normes et donc il manque
un point hello passer de passer 2014
ma prochaine partie le 16 juin à un open
moins de 2400 et à rendre un je vais
jouer à 1600 donc je vais tout faire
pour la gagner 6 Bagan c'est bon ah oui
mais si tu veux virtuellement oui
c'est pour ça qu'en fait
je veux une date peut-être
c'est pas pour faire le malin c'est que
d'une part que à faire
[Musique]
99 fois sur 100 donc effectivement
on va
question compliqué mais je stagne un peu
vers 500 et l'autre des conseils alors
oui
qui a très bien répondu d'ailleurs salut
François Jacques
donc oui il est tactique il est à clique
c'est c'est hyper important à ce niveau
là en fait il faut savoir que tu es
parti Flo qui flotte
tout est parti sans prendre parti bon se
jouer sur la tactique sur un truc que
vous allez oublier sur des pièces en
prises sur place comme ça et donc en
fait à ton niveau il faut déjà faire
attention aux caisses en prise et faire
de la tactique plus tu vas réussir à
anticiper des coups et avoir des pects
tactiques et plus tu vas réussir à pas
perdre de pièces et ben je te dis plus
tu vas gagner une partie
donc ça outre ça conseil très simple
pense toujours à prendre le centre pense
toujours à mettre ton roi en sécurité
déjà elle est tactique au moins seront
pas contre moi au début en début de
partie comme tu le dis très bien on met
les pions ensemble on se sont les
cavaliers ou on fait le petit rock dès
que tu peux on met le droit à l'abri
c'est important et on sort les pièces
toujours vers le milieu vers le centre
c'est vraiment voilà ça c'est un petit
peu les règles les règles
d'ouverture
au début après tu pourras te permettre
de les de les battre en brèche mais plus
tard d'ailleurs pour ceux qui sont qui
sont sur le stream tu vois je crois que
tu streamais à l'époque tu sais plus
maintenant c'est ça
ou tu streames encore Antoine c'est la
question moi oui et je ouais je
streamais pendant le confinement mais
tu
avais ta chaîne
ouais j'ai toujours une chaîne mais je
stream je stream plus de d'échec non et
donc moi je stream donc je vais vous
faire de la pub bon ma chaîne tant qu'à
faire bon pour ceux qui me connaissent
pas j'ai ma chaîne twitch alors
malheureusement comme je suis modo mais
je peux pas me faire la même à moi-même
s'il y a un modo qui est là
éventuellement me faire un petit saut
pas Wesley mais un petit STO
voilà merci le lien vers ma chaîne
twitch je stream quasiment tous les
jours sauf là avec l'événement de tlscum
on verra un petit peu comment je vais
faire parce que c'est assez vaillant
mais je stream quasiment tous les jours
j'ai aussi une ma chaîne youtube
ou tu as vraiment je fais pas mal de
petits shorts assez sympa donc en tout
cas je vous recommande ma chaîne ma
chaîne Youtube c'est tout comme mon
twitch exactement pareil et pas mal de
de matos d'ouverture en milieu de jeu
final
RAW to Amy aussi pas mal de pas mal de
parties que je commente etc
etc donc voilà en tout cas si vous
voulez progresser aussi et Ben
et ben au final il y a pas mal de trucs
pédagogiques sur ma chaîne donc
n'hésitez pas à aller voir quoi
un Road tohémique est presque terminé
donc
oui mais d'ailleurs j'ai d'autres idées
qui vont arriver bientôt ça je vous le
dis pas encore vous allez surprise
bientôt mais on va faire on va demander
si une fois que je passais ami bon je
sais pas encore ami donc on va voir mais
une fois que je passe la nuit est-ce que
je vais faire un retour GM et moi ma
réponse c'était que je ne voulais pas
vous mentir un RAW tout GM c'est quelque
chose qui pour moi est trop dur
je sais que je ne m'arriverai pas et je
ne fournirai pas l'effort pour être
grand maître parce que c'est trop trop
d'investissements et que ben il faut que
je travaille donc j'ai pas que ça à
faire et si jamais un temps limité et
que je voulais passer quand même là que
je pourrais l'être mais là j'ai pas
envie de fournir tous les efforts donc
j'ai pas envie de faire un rôle où GM
parce que je sais que je ne serai pas GM
donc je vais faire un on va garder quand
cette petite
on va dire
qui est très très sympa et que vous
aurez normalement les vidéos qui vont
sortir en même temps voir un tout petit
peu après le programme que je vais jouer
qui traîne du 16 au 18 juin avec le chat
qui qui
me fait un peu mes vidéos tout ça c'est
le mec s'occupe de tout ce qui est image
vidéo et voilà donc il sera où ce
tournoi c'est à Valence non jamais qu'on
Espagne à Valence Valence et donc ce à
Valence entre on aura moins de 2400
hello donc c'est pas toi je vais être
numéro 1 qu'on est loin c'est un
scandale de faire un tourne au moins de
2004 quand on est 2399 mais bon ça c'est
mon avis
[Musique]
mais
qu'est-ce que je veux dire le tournoi
peut-être tu as 15 joueurs je suis
rapide 2002 quasiment
et tu as peut-être 6 7 et demi
non c'est important là quand même ça
sera pas là
ça va être mais bon moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la route après le
reste c'est B9 quelle est la première et
qu'après en fait tu ne passes au
classement mensuel de la fuite 2004
c'est pas grave voilà je fais je fais ce
qu'il y a ça trône je fais 1 sur 7 en
perdant 1 non c'est 1/7
c'est bon à savoir et Mamé a pas fait du
tout B3 comme on évoquait tout à l'heure
ma mec qui a envoyé à quatre on va aller
voir ce qui s'est passé ma mais c'est la
rond 3 si c'est pas de bêtises
l'ordi d'ailleurs aime pas trop hein il
préfère vraiment la position des Noirs
ah ouais quand t'es pas précis en fait
ça peut ça peut être pas mal pour les
pour les Noirs en fait parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un problème sur le long
terme et le cavalier 3 ça peut poser
problème par exemple toi tu as proposé
l'idée du B4 bah on peut voir alors je
sais pas dans quel sport
mais par exemple je prends juste un
exemple un truc comme ça genre prise
please B3 et ben là on peut la regarder
B4 par exemple
en prise donc ça a l'air un peu
compliqué vous trouvez vraiment des
trucs tu vois il y a ça en prise sans
prise et sans prise
donc bon
j'ai une tactique encore encore le
tactique je crois mais je crois je vais
pas leur dire tu sais tu vois mon écran
mais à dire
et je te dis tiens bouge ton cavalier
ah merde
je mange
ah non c'est horrible
après je sais pas tu récupères quand
même mais bon maintenant
c'est 4 et ça va être égal waouh
et en fait c'est le même thème si tu
fais à la place de jouer prises là que
tu fais quand même le 4 je crois que
j'ai ça
peut-être faire un truc là en fait
c'est un pion de gagner pour les blancs
je prenais comme ça
peut-être que ce que
un truc pas mal en fait
c'est compliqué hein c'est c'est
intéressant mais on voit qu'il est quand
même des ressources en thé noir
on voit surtout que la position peut se
liquider de pas mal de manières et je
pense que déjà ma mère doit compter
là-dessus là ouais et puis aussi c'est
vrai que le il faut dire mais ici les
joueurs ils ont plus trop de temps il a
on voit déjà à 32 minutes à la pendule
pour Paris pour jouer encore 17 coups
ça fait un peu plus de ça fait même pas
2 minutes par coup là
je vous le dis parce que on a l'habitude
la même les joueurs qui sont ici ils ont
l'habitude toute l'habitude d'avoir des
positions avec incrément une partie
infamant là il y a pas d'incrément
l'imprimant arrive au 40e coup donc tu
dois rire 41 coups pour avoir 10
secondes par coup sinon tu n'auras pas
d'imprimante
ça fait une très très grosse différence
cette absence d'incrément on peut
absolument pas se permettre de se
laisser 5 minutes
alors là si elle veut être grosse
on a parlé de tout ça pour défendre ses
quatre venir en Détroit donc il y a
plusieurs possibilités mais en tout cas
alors pas mal pour les Noirs en tout cas
j'aime bien
alors est-ce que on pourrait pas aller
voir un peu ce qui se passe chez firou
chez les jeunes elle est arrivée en G4
mais elle est redescendue aussi sec la
partie très vite
[Musique]
j'enlève le Caval attaqué puis moi
j'attaque ta dame il est revenu en E5 et
d'un E2 ok donc ça en l'air si bouge le
cavalier et là bas c'est chaud j'ai du
camaïeu 4 regardez il y a des
menaces pour le cavalier sur le plan
aussi
simple ça peut aussi être une menace
l'impression que la pollution elle est
complètement folle
hyper attention pour les deux camps mais
surtout pour les Noirs parce que les les
coups blancs du style sp4c5 ou cavalue
E4 même Caval C5 c'est tellement facile
à jouer en fait que
[Musique]
il faut être plus alerte niveau avec les
Noirs
case blanche assez monstrueuse
le système est faible effectivement et
le Caval qui peut se pointer en C5 je
sais pas si tu l'as montré sur le
Caval jouer de la part de Google
donc peut-être qu'il pense que c'est un
échange quoi
j'ai pris un pion contre une pièce je
prends une pièce mais je prends un pion
ok mais ça a fait vu encore plus cette
histoire de A3 à 3 va tomber à coup sûr
enfin de
à la fin de cette séquence d'échange je
pense
ben d'un côté
ouais au moins je suis actif là je te
prends juste la dame et je te fais tout
3 alors de là à faire attention
intéressant
non en fait je suis actif avec les noirs
de Google parce que c'est vrai que on
parlait de ce pion aussi ce qui est un
problème tout le temps et avec cette
horreur de coup bah en fait tu vas
échanger enfin si on joue d'avoir un
forfait qu'on vient de voir donc au
final tu vas échanger
l'option C3 qui était là
et c'est un bon deal pour les Noirs
parce que maintenant c'est plus là
et du coup tout est tranquille quoi
alors est-ce qu'on peut se permettre de
pas reprendre le Caval tout de suite
d'envoyer un petit coup de tour à dés
est-ce que ça fait quelque chose
je reviens à la maison je pense
avoir des C4 peut-être
B5 derrière pour bien jouer qu'on
retombe fou et éventuellement ces cinq
C4
il faut prendre le Caval ouais je pense
qu'il faut
comme le seul coup par leur dire après 4
[Musique]
ah oui
c'est le seul coup de l'ordi bonne
chance
en fait
quand on voit c'est logique mais il
pensait c'est autre chose
le Fou est perdu
certes donc tant qu'à faire vas-y
mange-le pas
le jour où je prends aussi s'imaginons
ça c'est très mal je pense parce que
quand tu fais ça bah écoute je te mate
quoi
effectivement sur l'ordi sur toutes les
autres variantes c'est
avantage noir
en fait je pense quand vraiment tu es
dans la partie
c'est un coup que tu que tu vas trouver
pour nous on trouve pas parce que ben on
n'a pas l'ordi et puis on fait partie
par la partie on rentre pas vraiment
deep
et donc on n'a pas eu tout vu je pensais
ça direct j'avais pas vu qu'elle prend
ma carte
une fois quand on le voit ça apparaît
hyper logique hyper naturel hyper
évident mais effectivement il pense
quand même compliqué surtout alors il
avait forcément imaginé qu'il pouvait y
avoir du Caval B4 à les raisins mais là
il est en grande réflexion
et je pense qui se dit que la position
est plus en fait il comprend là en ce
moment que sur juste c'est prendre B4 il
va être un peu moins bien
avec cette activité
qui a une tour en D2 comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure la position de noir est
super active quoi moi je pense que les
deux joueurs ont vu la suite et les deux
joueurs ont anticipé tous les cinq
en fait à ce niveau là pas compte mais
les mecs c'est des machines quoi
vous avez vraiment le point de vue d'un
amateur complet et c'est vrai que j'ai
du mal
oui ça a l'air dur mais en fait vous
savez c'est pas logique
ça c'est logique
enfin d'un point de vue tu vois quand on
explique c'est logique et à ce niveau là
c'est à dire que je pense que un coup
comme ça en partie même moi je le trouve
en fait
mais là tu dis qu'ils l'ont vu en amont
quoi oui mais le mec c'est des machines
à calculer donc t'inquiète pas que je
suis sûr qu'ils ont acquisé c'est pas
trop à ce niveau là de 1800 euros
200750 et pas trop le genre de la maison
de faire un coup hop j'ai pas vu
c'est pas le genre de la maison
c'est évident qu'il a pas sursauter en
voyant qu'elle profite 4 non Emmanuel
il va pas tout simplement plus quoi il
va manger tempo et puis voilà quoi
je suis convaincu que
cette position est dans le genre
anticipé depuis quelques coups
et que bah là il vérifie ses variantes
etc mais je suis sûr voilà je te prends
un pari il va te faire plus simple
effectivement mais qu'est-ce qu'il est
venu faire en G4 avec Saddam ben
peut-être que le cavalier ici l'embêtait
à cause de cavalier F4 qui
là il se dit qu'avec dame G4 qui force
cavalier E5 et peut-être que ici bah il
trou de cavaliers F4 donnait trop de
joie je sais pas j'essaie de comprendre
mais
j'ai 4 au final sa force tout ça le
Cavalaire
ouais mais j'ai un deuxième qui est
arrivé
parce que le tour des 7 ça a pas trop de
sens
on va manger là tu manges là et
maintenant question qu'est-ce qu'on fait
j'ai dame Détroit qu'elle est
intéressante
aussi ce qui va forcément tomber un jour
on dirait
qu'est-ce qu'on comment on joue cette
pause
mais bon peut-être que je suis juste en
fait
mais bon
je vous rappelle qu'on est sans ordi
donc pour nous c'est aussi un gros
exercice c'est difficile
je vous avoue que des fois je branche un
peu l'ordi pour suivre le rythme de
stouf parce que c'est difficile
mais je galère un peu
parce que c'est
tiens même nous avec l'ordi des fois on
a du mal à les suivre alors que eux ils
ont pas l'ordi et ils voient tout quoi
c'est hyper dur ou les cinq c'est hyper
dur j'ai 5 ans
comment tu vas
j'espère que tu vas bien plaisir de te
voir
derrière il se peut que très bientôt je
viens de te parler j'ai
quelque chose à te demander à te
demander à te proposer mais on en
reparlera plus tard
ce coup fait quand même plus réfléchir à
les raisins que
il se passe des choses super
intéressantes côté carlten karwana
moi qui ai une autre partie qui t'attire
mais en fait que car wanna on avait dit
qu'il ferait jamais F5 et puis le voilà
qui pousse F5
ouais ouais ok alors attends on va aller
voir je regarde juste rapidement Abdou
bon ça c'est un petit peu liquidé mais
il y a plein de choses qui se passent on
va le voir rapidement car de scène
il s'avère que après Carsan a doublé les
tours sur C comme il l'avait envisagé
il a joué F5 ok bon F5 c'est un coup à
cette thématique quand même assez
positions tu vois il y a deux faiblesses
quand même chez les chez les noirs
on a parlé de plan du type ouais je
crois tout un cavalier bouge tapais sur
le 6 on a parlé de cavailler 5 fois
plein de trucs
F4 en fait on ferme la tour là en fait
alors déjà il y a F4 qui est très
concret
un coup ça menace la tour je l'avais
même pas vu
mais moi je pensais bon style est plus
de taquet moi je moi je pensais
le couplet
et mais même sans fuf 4 et ben tu sens
un peu que des pions sont complètement
faibles et que maintenant comme cavalier
F4 fois H3 enfin par exemple
moi je trouve que positionnellement
c'est un coup auquel j'aurais pas pensé
parce qu'on se débarrasse
là en l'occurrence la menace est très
concret 4 ouais d'ailleurs c'est ce que
tu dis un lien c'est une faiblesse donc
en fait très souvent tu peux
d'un avantage à un autre par exemple un
avantage de la structure d'un avantage
sur le pion aussi qui est arrivé mais tu
peux très bien échanger davantage pour
un autre avantage qui est après F5 ça
peut être un partage matériel après fou
R4 mais aussi ça peut être aussi
maintenant avec le pion dessin qui
risque d'être en prise et le fou qui va
s'activer sur case blanche tu vois donc
tu tu joues plus sur le pion arrière
mais plus sur les caches longues je
manière générale et sur les deux points
qui sont faibles donc c'est intéressant
de culture switcher tellement peur à
l'autre
et là j'aime beaucoup donc là il y a eu
ou à trois ouais il a continué à jouer
de manière la plus active possible
disant si tu veux faire du F4
renouvelle la menace
alors là comment ce que je joue un truc
avalé B4 c'est un coup ça me paraît très
très chaud
en fait parce que j'ai peur
je te le montrer donc
je vais réussir à réagir
et après F4 ça a l'air de voir et j'ai
l'impression que tu vas prendre cher sur
le case blanche et que tu fasses cavaler
les B4
ouf j'ai l'impression que c'est le même
problème ou B4 a été joué donc ça
empêche
est-ce que vous pouvez jouer autre chose
je retourne peut-être
tourner il y a plus la présence
4 ça me ferait changer
mais dans ce cas là
est-ce que F4 enfin peut-être la prise
et qu'avait pas aussi forte
que dans l'autre mais enfin ça me gêne
ça me gêne j'aime pas du tout la
production de Magnus
peut-être que je peux manger en fait
pardon
il est solide il est là mais c'est vrai
que cette possibilité
c'est un peu la même mais maintenant
j'ai une carte dans le cadre peut-être
qui peut être
mais je sais pas peut-être qu'avec
c'est pas comme ce que je peux jouer
mais je suis pas fans je
sais pas
j'ai toujours aussi mauvais non le foot
casse blanche ok peut-être qu'il arrive
en B5 quand même pour s'échanger ou
s'activer là évidemment sur Caval
B400
ouais c'est chaud
pour l'instant cette tour C2
pour commencer
pas forcément un bon avantage de donner
la colonne c'est facilement
mais bon on va c'est du jeu en fait
c'est bizarre c'est un petit peu
mais j'ai l'impression qu'en fait avec
les Blancs on va pouvoir thé au pire du
pire c'est l'activité un peu embêtante
on prendra la qualité et
je suis pas inquiet là pour les blancs
dans cette position
car voilà a fait un peu d'humour bien
placé dans son six Squad podcast je sais
que c'est quoi les
trucs
là ok
je connais ouais
ok non j'avais pas du tout suivi
par contre là je j'avais tout à l'heure
si vous voulez je trace les montrer en
stream j'avais les vidéos de du
confessionnal donc j'en ai une de
Nakamura et une de Tari
est-ce que est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres
qui sont sortis depuis là je crois pas
j'ai pas eu de
réponse j'ai pas eu d'autres
on est impatient d'avoir une de Carl sed
évidemment c'est souvent les plus
savoureux ouais non j'ai
un gris peut être insupportable aussi
après pendant la partie bon c'est
toujours spéciale de se lever
et l'action continue et là c'est
vraiment de la vraie action alors il y a
une nulle il y a une nul
et du coup on va avoir très bientôt
cette Armageddon c'est avec en cas de
nul on a l'Armageddon donc tous ces
liquidés au final voir rapidement ce qui
s'est passé il cavalier donc on était là
on avait parlé plein de lignes on avait
parlé de B4 qui était marrant d'ailleurs
je prends ici et je prends là c'est le
même thème avec la dame qui a attaqué
cette fois c'est très mal donc il y a eu
prise en B3 waouh toutes les personnes
prises
manger manger
très solide de la part de Paris il a pas
tremblé ouais alors que il a décidé de
liquider un peu Carola de manière
tactique c'est quand même assez
intéressant parce qu'il a choisi de
prendre en B4 il a pris le ouf et sur
Caval prend cette fois il a pris en F6
en E6 excusez-moi en réussissent donc
faut prendre complètement forcer et
maintenant j'imagine qu'il va vouloir
placer son Caval en F4
une belle partie là ce plan de 5 qui va
bien bien souffrir
ce que j'arrive à le sasa quoi
ça suffira pas toujours échanger les
fous
il y a deux qui est en prise dans
peut-être dans certaines armes mais pour
l'instant faut régler le problème de ce
foodcast blanche attaqué on a la colonne
C mais qu'est-ce qui se passe pas grand
chose
pour l'instant
des cases incroyables pour nos cavaliers
côté blanc
ouais c'est pas mal une grosse pression
qui va arriver sur le pion des 5 on peut
penser à cavalier la colonne c'est pour
les Noirs mais est-ce que ça passe
suffire c'est qu'une colonne là il y a
qu'une ça ça emprise une grosse pression
sur le case blanche j'aime pas du tout
la position
à la pollution des noix j'aime
absolument pas la position des noirs de
Magnus Carlsen champion du monde je vais
me tenir informé rapidement savoir quand
est-ce que va se dérouler la partie
Armageddon parce que vous savez bien
qu'on la suivre aussi mais on peut pas
la suivre
enfin on peut la suivre mais j'aimerais
bien qu'on suive un petit peu tout en
même temps je pense que vous mettra la
vue Multiboard pour pour l'Armageddon
mais on va voir un peu donc là Magnus
alors est-ce que tu vois qu'on aille
voir à partir un peu rose là il y a eu
fougères je te l'avais assuré dans le
crack français qui rate pas ça
évidemment non
je pense à ce niveau-là c'est standard
c'est vraiment pas c'est que nous on
voit ça qui est qu'est-ce qu'il fait
quoi on se dit mais il faut emprise et
oui ça alors ça a l'air
d'être un coup extraterrestre mais au
final quand on explique le pourquoi du
comment et ben c'est hyper logique et à
ce niveau là ça rate pas quoi c'est
c'est assez évident en fait donc
on pourrait pas juste prendre en B4
aussi on l'a pas évoqué ça parce que je
parle une tour
G5 il y a eu ça et c'est prend B4 voilà
donc c'est la partie donc maintenant
écoute il y a toujours un petit peu plus
pour Google mais ça un peu faible le
bouquet peut-être
il n'ira par rendre
à
mireza d'ailleurs il y a un coup que je
viens de trouver enfin que j'ai trouvé
j'en trouve une idée en tout cas pour
pour bocage qui m'a l'air intéressantes
je sais pas si c'est possible mais
j'aime bien l'idée ici
j'ai pu en dire une bêtise allez allez
lance-toi lance-toi
j'ai proposé
doucement
il y a une pression monstre sur ce
cavalier sur le plan incises et en fait
de te rendre quoi enfin un vendredi
7 par exemple
on est trop faible sur casse blanche
c'est ça que tu veux dire je sais pas
l'impression que je suis trop
heureux de jouer ça avec les Noirs
tendu tu tiens tout sur un fil
je prends ta dame je prends
finalement à la fin à la fin tu es cloué
quoi tu risques de perdre ton temps ok
ok
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que tous les
cinq étaient très intéressant parce que
sur H3 ben tu as les un petit peu les
motifs avec le matin en H5 et je viens
d'avoir un an
ok non je viens d'avoir une notice sur
slack je pensais que c'était
dans 15 minutes donc il est il est 20h à
20h15 on aura l'Armageddon voilà je
pensais que c'était donc ils auront ils
garderont les mêmes couleurs c'est à
dire Mamet avec blanc et taré avec les
noirs et donc tari aura 3 minutes de
moins et si il fait nul et il remporte
le demi point non le
si tu gagnes la partie lente tu gagnes 3
points si tu perds la partie lente tu
gagnes 0
point minimum mais quand tu gagnes un
magasin donc tu peux avoir un et demi si
tu gagnes
l'Armageddon après après avoir
par contre si tu perds un magasin
donc
quand même c'est vrai que gagner aux
échecs et plus
valorise valorisant que gagner en fait
dans un magasin
bah oui ça va forcer un peu les joueurs
à gagner des parties quoi ça va être
sympa donc voilà donc prise en baguette
là ça va être choquant
parce que
tu as une grosse pression de partout là
écoute c'est logique et pas logique
alors d'un côté alors pas logiquement je
vais dire pas logique mais
comme ce pieuvre perdu un jour
et ben on aime bien en fait avec le
cavalier G3 toujours mettre un pion en
G6 pour empêcher qu'avec cinq ou en H5
déjà
intéressant profilactique sur le long
terme mais aussi sûrement maintenant en
G7 ce qui est très logique c'est qu'il a
rien à craindre sur case noire quoi
parce que lui il a monopole sur 15 mois
et les blancs en fait ou que l'on va
poser on met des pièces sur la case de
son fou c'est hyper logique en fait
quand on voit
G6 c'est très très fort
parce que maintenant
j'ai 7 bon là il va arrêter de manger
parce que maintenant sur la prise prise
des rois j'ai 7 tu vois et tout à
l'heure
sans quoi
je ris de me faire clouer peut-être
quoique
mais attention que c'est encore cavalier
F4
qui se regarde mais peut-être juste
aussi ça
dans quel sens je fais
la tour de vent je bouffe et tu mets le
roi là c'est le matin de coup et
c'est pour ça que le Cavé devrait rester
là pour
tout à l'heure mais après j'ai 6
maintenant qui avait trois commence à
devenir une sérieuse menace mais il y a
eu tourner un qui est arrivé à temps
pour parer la menace
donc écoute ben
tranquille jusque là
on a refusé d'aller le voir mais bon là
pour écouter le bon aka
malgré toutes ces complications
d'ailleurs la partie fil rouge jaguet la
barre d'évaluation de tremble pas
un gros un bon gros zéro ça que je
trouve ça magique quand tu vois en fait
quand tu vois en fait ces gens-là jouer
ils arrivent tout le temps à
garder un équilibre de d'évaluation
alors que nous on comprend rien la
partie on voit tout est en prise et on
comprend rien et eux ils arrivent
toujours à garder un équilibre ça montre
à quel point on joue pas la mesure en
fait c'est assez frustrant des fois
quand on voit c'est assez dingue c'est
assez dingue ouais
[Musique]
qui fait une batterie sur la diagonale
et sur cavale de 4 par exemple sur un
cavalier 3 échec
est-ce qu'un parable moi j'ai dû
apprendre mais je parle
c'est quand même pas mal pour les pour
les Noirs donc oui
pour l'instant
parce qu'on va faire ce qu'on va faire
une petite pause maintenant je pense ça
fait trois heures qu'on est en string on
n'a pas encore fait de pause
on fait une petite pause on revient dans
5 minutes et on sera en forme pour
l'Armageddon entre
orientari et chacun ma média Rohff et
pour
les couleurs déjà ma mère elle est
blonde
c'est vrai
[Musique]
moi je mise
je vais miser
noir
non on n'aura pas le boîtier arcings
je vais vous montrer d'autres vidéos qui
sont qui sont vos différentes mais voilà
là c'est franchement je suis pas content
de l'overlay qu'on a sur cheesecum on a
vraiment de c'est la c'est vraiment une
des premières fois où je suis vraiment
content de ce qu'on a en tout cas vous
montrer en termes de de overlay quoi
donc on part pour une pub vous voyez un
petit peu ce qu'on a à vous montrer et
puis on vient d'ici 5 minutes à tout de
suite à toute
je pars sur celle là quel est le
meilleur moyen de suivre n'importe quel
événement échiquier surpris a du monde
au tournoi des candidats en passant par
le speechess ou les titles
tuesday.com/aventure tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
qui est qui parle du coup d'avant
Armageddon donc je vais vous la montrer
un
là
[Musique]
ça va être l'heure du début de
l'Armageddon maintenant
vous l'avez écoutez dans le magasin
et il a l'air confiance avant l'armée et
là
en confiance il s'est dit que bon la
partie c'est bien passé pour lui il
était mieux tout le temps il a recruté
un petit peu de pas avoir
mis plus de pression mais qu'une nulle
qu'un mec noir
c'est quand même pas mal et qui allait
un petit peu prendre l'air pour un peu
ce qui est passé pour cette armag donc
un magasin qui tu as commencé dans
quelques instants est-ce qu'on partirait
pas sur la vue de tous les déchets qui
pour un magasin ça te dit ou pas
on va essayer et si c'est pas bien vous
me dites
côté Magnus Magnus a donné un pion en
réalité subir la pression ça a commencé
on les voit en haut allez c'est parti
l'Armageddon donc de voir l'Armageddon
et de tout voir un petit peu en même
temps donc c'était intéressant donc pour
ceux qui sont sur le téléphone je suis
désolé peut-être que vous avez pas bien
voir
mais je pense que la clarko c'est pas
mal de passer sur cette vue là un G4 qui
part directement
on revoit
et hyper chaud hyper concret qui a des
blancs qui doivent gagner absolument
je t'avais dit qu'il allait envoyer du
pâté et là ça part avec du gros G4 moi
je serais tarif j'aurais déjà très très
peur là qu'est-ce que tu fais il y a
j'ai un qui arrive il y a H4 qui arrive
la marée qui va être immédiate à le
droit et la dame qui va arriver en C de
et ça va faire des attaques très
dangereuses alors pour voir s'il y a pas
du tout et si ceci qui peut être être
possible surtout en général donc
malheureusement je peux pas faire de
flèches désolé
très concret mais on est quand même
content d'avoir vu colonne j'ai souffrir
non n'hésitez pas à me dire sur le chat
ce que vous pensez de cette vue là
est-ce que vous préférez que je mette la
vue sur le l'Armageddon et de temps en
temps éventuellement on repasse sur
notre revue que c'est un peu petit à mon
avis pour eux et puis surtout ça bouge
pas trop sur les autres échiquier donc
peut-être qu'on peut mettre bientôt très
vite en fait c'est vrai
allez on va on va sur l'Armageddon du
coup c'était la ville de numéro 3
il a pris en G4 et il a fait F5 tout de
suite parce que moi j'ai pas il faut que
je trouve la partie
Armageddon 1 il est là
par contre je me suis trompé de scène
voilà j'ai mis celle où tu n'es pas là
j'ai disparu et tu es revenu voilà
du coup de baguette magique et donc en
fait voilà ça c'est un Gambie à cette
typique dans ses positions ou en fait
voilà il a fait je 4 ou par an on doit
G4 pour ouvrir la colonne g donc c'est
hyper agressif
et d'ailleurs
cette position
il me semble que c'est franchement pas
terrible mais bon ça du rapide c'est
chaud c'est du pur mais j'adore ce style
de jeu
minute elle renvoie 8 minutes 37 contre
5 minutes 43 donc on joue à 10 contre 7
10 minutes pour les blancs contre 7 pour
les Noirs mais des Blancs ont obligation
de gagner la partie il y a absolument
zéro incrément ko
il y a zéro incrément
et on va un peu ce qui va se passer donc
là elle m'a dit horror qui a plus de
temps la pendule qui doit gagner quand
même pas trop trop
perte de temps dans l'ouverture parce
que sinon
[Musique]
tu es au départ
sera nul
Tariq a envoyé une structure Stonewall
en fait
tout simplement il s'est mis en mode en
mode tortue là il évite les coups il m'a
met lui il veut ouvrir tout ça il envoie
des quatre à cinq qui est joué par le
genre norvégien
alors pourquoi il y a un magasin parce
que c'est le format du tournoi tout
simplement en cas de nul en partie lente
il y a un magasin et pour les points
pour compter les points c'est très
simple le gagnant de la partie lente
gagne 3 points le perdant ganzé
dans on a au moins un point mais le
gagnant de l'Armageddon marquera en tout
un point et demi
si on fait nul en partie lente on a
assuré d'avoir un point
et un demi point qui est donné en bonus
pour le vainqueur de star mckenon ça
peut valoir à la fin de ça c'est un peu
comme logiciel bleu une manière de faire
penalty à la fin du match c'est ça ils
aiment pas les nuls c'est norvégien non
mais je trouve ça marrant parce que là
ils ont essayé d'accélérer un petit peu
le rythme dans le fait que la cadence
c'est deux heures ko plus 10 secondes
par coup 40e bah écoute ça a l'air sympa
ce qui peut se passer des choses assez
dingues
[Musique]
je te tiendrai au courant peut-être
qu'il faudra un moment qu'on aille voir
ce qui se passe
donc là les Noirs peut pas faire nul
pour gagner et le blanc oui alors là en
cas de nul c'est des Noirs qui gagnent
voilà
tout simplement ils ont 3 minutes de
moins mais l'avantage de la nul
après avoir les fins inverses de limiter
la prise de risque pendant la partie
classique
j'ai envie de dire que tu gagnes la
partie classique qui gagne 3 points
quand même il gagne deux fois une nuit
donc la prise de risque que
j'ai l'impression
enfin ça dépend de la pause mais
[Musique]
normalement quand tu fais nul tu marques
à moitié des points d'accord au début
c'est un pari moi je mets un point sur
la table si on peut vivre le partage et
si tu gagnes etc il y a un point sur la
table et en fait
si tu es ma tenue tu es pas encore sûr
d'avoir de mes points tu vois le vrai
demi point parce que le vrai demi point
il faut gagner l'armée dedans pour avoir
le ennemi point tu vois parce que là
sur une partie vue ce format là il y a
pas un point il y a trois points sur la
table
le gagnant de la partie
et
il va pas y avoir des dingueries avec H5
cavalles G6 un jour tu as fait donc
clairement être un coup Bobby échec
c'est un cavalier en H6 je crois que il
veut tout mettre sur G7
panache il est carrément en train
d'attaquer à fond mais il fait le don
quand même le jeune tarif non c'est
chaud c'est chaud après tari et lui il
est plus solide donc c'est des positions
où chacun et jouent dans son style un
media me donner un pion pour ça et là il
y a plus que une minute trente d'écart
entre deux jours quasiment 2 minutes
d'écart alors qu'au début il y en avait
trois
donc tu arrives qui joue assez vite
quand même mais attention que la
position est très compliquée faut pas
non plus
faire n'importe quoi je pense être dans
la 5 pour venir à deux mais bon on verra
pas grand chose après moi
on va pas prendre le pion H4 qui est en
prise ça serait de la folie furieuse
puisque le colonne HSG pour les tours
blanches qui se prennent
à cœur joie ils ont droit à cœur joie et
on prendra déjà G7 à minima non mais là
un plan pour les blancs qui avait été 5
ou des trois et on
essaie de t'ouvrir la position avec F3 4
essayer de faire quelque chose quoi
ça m'a l'air complètement complètement
[Musique]
normal
la structure noire est difficile de
percer cette structure Stonewall là
c'est quand même du costaud ouais
surtout depuis qu'on a pu le pion G5
j'ai 4
enfin j'ai tout simplement on a plus de
pions j'ai pour venir attaquer cette
structure où est-ce qu'on la touche en
fait où est-ce qu'on la touche
[Musique]
de 4 coups je fais ça sans pardon 1 2 3
l'ordi de ne Fabiano très très bien donc
faudra qu'on aille voir ça après ouais
très très bien et je regardais de mon
côté là et là c'est plutôt Ariane qui
est très très bien après le G5
si tu fais nul c'est zéro perd ses 0
donc tu joues juste pour mater quoi
[Musique]
ma médié
là c'est c'est clair et puis là il
commence à creuser un petit peu des
carreaux de temps là il pose des
problèmes pratiques
ça a été joué par
pari donc
j'imagine que tu as envie de prendre ou
non non cavale prend et c'est encore
solide c'est dingue non mais F3 regarde
direct c'est clairement par contre pour
faire un petit attention il peut y avoir
un thème tactile qui pourrait arriver
c'est le jour où toujours quatre quoi
marrant pourrait être un jour qui avait
été 5
l'idée c'est que si tu manges dans ces 5
j'ai chaque
et mat délicieux et si tu m'entends mon
cavalier je menace d'un échec et qui
prend mes trois qui fera quasiment maths
le problème de cavalier 5 c'est que
souvent je mange ton fou et ensuite mais
bon la réponse je suis pas sûr que ça
marche
donc faut faire attention à ce thème de
kabye C50
il pense pas trop attaquer le roi blanc
dans cette position
dans la 2 pour
evançait
le four B2 très bon défenseur évidemment
c'est ça commence à prendre pas mal de
sens
mais là il y a la cassé
l'ordinateur est-ce que j'ai pas ça et
ça attention à toi
attention à toi qui pourrait être une
très très grosse menace et j'imagine
qu'il pense à ça et ça
pour essayer de manger ici
c'est la partie roi C2
20 OK
[Musique]
c'est quoi
c'est très chaud
dans la tête mais je calcule pas
l'idée
je comprends pas
ah c'est cavalier
là en fait il veut faire ça oui
là c'est maths de partout quoi et il y a
ça en l'air ouais bon c'est trop
compliqué c'est hyper compliqué moi
j'aurais fait Cara
la tête
il se prendra pas qu'elle va lève 7 mais
est-ce que
tu veux manger et il considère qu'il a
du jeu
et attends là pour les Noirs là c'est
une vraie dame ouais
ça marche pas
besoin de le faire
donc je pensais à Carré point accessible
j'oublie que la tour pour revenir
rapidement
encore attention
quand même chaud à naviguer cette
affaire
très professionnel ma mec qui va
complètement défendre contre les menaces
de des tournois et qui va du coup il
envoie F4 là tu arrives
4,5 ça a l'air pas mal ce pion qui râle
piocher tu vas le prendre plus tard et
même si on prend la pas mal aussi
d'ouvrir le cadence
certes je me dis que ça oui c'est très
bien mais je préfère faire la même chose
il a fait des deux aussi
c'est pas défendable pour baisser
dans quelques instants c'est terminé
4 pour 8 en F5 moi je prends tout
ça change toutes les pièces
attention que ça peut se terminer en
Bullet cette histoire
ouais une minute 12 pour ma mais il faut
la finir il faut la finir
il faut la finir mais normalement ça a
quand même
il garde un câlins
[Musique]
c'est déjà de passer d'une cadence lente
à directement à une partie rapide
quasiment Blitz très bizarre c'est pas
facile
parce qu'on a on n'a pas les réflexes ça
va les réfléchir encore à te reprendre
hein alors que ambulette il faut y aller
quoi il faut jouer vite quoi
et juste
là ça peut flag il faut jouer la carie
là
en train de cliquer hyper vite et là le
fait d'être en IRL se dit tiens en fait
il peut pas se permettre alors que là vu
sa position il peut tout se permettre
c'est fini
mais bon il y a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de retard il y a tout qui tombe
là tout simplement il y a les pions même
le pion B qui va tranquillement pousser
et on pourrait changer ce qui fait 5
secondes à la pendule
4 secondes à la pendule C6 d'un point
ici elle bouge le roi il a fait un échec
c'est pas possible c'est la vraie vie là
c'est la vraie vie il faut prendre la
pièce avec sa main il faut appuyer sur
la pendule avec sa main c'est impossible
et oui magnifique dame Pro 7 qui va
donner un cavalier Winda main grande
question cavalier grande filouterie
grande question se fait fourchette ok
qui a gagné son Armageddon on a Wesley
sceau qui a terminé aussi enfin sa
partie nul avec ma caméra
il faut absolument qu'on retrouve voir
carwana parce que là il est complètement
gagnant il s'est passé quelques coups
mais alors là ça c'est très très bien
passé pour lui
[Musique]
qui chauffe pas mal qu'on ira voir après
aussi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le temps
comment ils ont le temps la pendule ils
ont un peu plus de temps ils ont 25000
mais côté
minutes pour jouer six coups et qui a
une position dominante il a mis ses
cavale au milieu ben j'ai l'impression
que c'est celui-là c'est perdu en fait
juste ouais il a gagné un gros pion et
puis
cavalier
[Musique]
c'est la catastrophe tactique là pour
les tu es sûr qu'il parle d'une pièce
dans toutes les valeurs non c'est pas
grave
ok voilà
[Musique]
je bouge ma tour je vais aller
peut-être des idées comme ça parce que
si tu vas là je peux maths
[Musique]
de gagner
ah oui
encore
ouais ouais mais bon
ok
tu vas là bon tu m'as tout en prison
ça c'est ce que l'ordinateur
mais ça a l'air quand même extrêmement
fort pour
les pour les blancs histoire
de sombrer là parce que après s'il
arrive à esquiver toutes les menaces
tactiques ce qui est peu probable
d'après la barre des balles il aura des
finales qui sont un peu meilleur
alors est-ce que on va voir un petit peu
fille un peu ce qui nous fait ici 3 4 3
on s'est arrêté où
la barre est très critique de la pose de
les raisins alors faut prendre 600
arrêté oui après tour B1 on s'est arrêté
à
un truc comme ça
il arrive à être à la fois à défendre et
en même temps un paquet quoi je trouve
ça génial ce qui fait que non est-ce
qu'on prendrait pas juste F2 tout de
suite attends
il y a eu besoin
peut-être pris en H3 prise en géant
ok
pour défendre notre tour c'est pas
si je mange juste c'est pas le problème
ah oui il y a le fou ok oui mais là il y
a dame prend F2
et sur et surtout D1 il y aura Caval à
la fin
[Musique]
nouvelle confession
salut Françoise
[Musique]
et donc
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire
[Musique]
après la partie ça va être croustillant
je sais pas si vous voulez le voir ou
vous voulez rester un peu avant la
partie encore 20 minutes quand même ici
pour ce petit coup
faut qu'on reste un peu sur parce que ma
mère s'est terminée
tu veux rester sur quoi sur l'action la
gouquette ou Caro rapidement
vous voyez cette partie là c'est
contre
deux pions chacun ça va ça va faire nul
très bientôt et
[Musique]
et en plus ils ont ils sont 44e coup
donc là ils ont 6 minutes 10 contre
1600028 + 10 secondes par coup voilà
donc il récupère pas de temps
voilà c'est ça ah ouais compliqué quand
même salut aussi à Arnaud Arnaud qui
dit bonjour à François
Arnaud salut Arnaud François vous
arrivez donc pour Balzac
vous arrivez pile à l'heure pour l'autre
date il y a deux parties qui pourraient
s'avérer décisives qui ont l'air bien
parti pour être venu
ouais alors après il a fait cavale C3
Magnus on peut peut-être retrouver
[Musique]
au pire j'ai ça ça peut pas venir
et il y aura l'idée et sur roi G7 il y
avait l'idée tout recettes j'imagine
et
H6 ouais ouais ça déjà avec menace de
gagner tout ouais
c'est complètement perdant ben écoute
Carine qui a perdu dans cette partie
47 qui a 0 points du coup et carmena qui
prend une belle option en battant Magnus
avec les Blancs lors de cette première
partie donc je vous rappelle les points
le score on a quand on marque quand on
gagne la partie lente on gagne trois
points en général quand on perd on
marque malheureusement zéro et quand le
match nul on a au moins un point sur les
trois et le demi-point qui reste il va
être on va dire gagner lors de
l'Armageddon qui se jouera en cas de
match nul donc
il vient de jouer un superbe coup
esthétiquement l'ami Google de ma radio
31 cavales c'est un je trouve que c'est
très beau alors on va regarder ce que
j'ai très esthétique
il vient de jouer alors la tour B7
là tu attaques là là
il a peut-être des idées ok non je veux
sacrifier trop tôt mais peut-être il a
juste pour tourner un
faut faire quelque chose pour le fou
peut-être juste simplement le est-ce
qu'on peut à son a le droit de mettre le
four en F4 sans se faire mater c'est une
bonne question
j'aimerais bien ne pas me faire mater ok
là je vais peut-être me faire mal dessus
c'est qu'elle a pu en maths plus rapide
pour nous bon j'ai trois emprises à
tourcongé deux fois
et le jolimat
[Musique]
j'ai trois prises et ma douleur et prise
à F2
de jouer
ah oui
prise et échec qui a abandonné
directement par ce que Dame des 6 je
pense que c'est le prochain coup qui va
attaquer
aussi à lireas c'est une grosse grosse
partie c'était une grosse game et non
seulement il a jamais pris toute la
partie mais c'est quand même fait
attaquer le roi
c'est clair il avait le droit
de de Ali resa qui a raté il faut
prendre HS je vous rappelle ici dans ce
début de partie il a joué ici des cartes
avec les Blancs et sur eux prendre des
quatre apparemment il y a l'erreur assez
fou prend H6
on prend un 6 ici et surtout on prend
avec d'un point de 4 et c'était la
misère
alors j'ai un troisième résultat non le
résultat que j'ai ici c'est ma manière
bien sûr donc il nous reste une seule
partie pour l'instant c'est la partie de
abdos contre
Nakamura c'est ça et donc on va avoir on
va avoir un voilà le
l'Armageddon de de Saw et Nakamura qui
va commencer dans un instant et très
probablement bien sûr aussi l'armagement
les parties des joueurs donc ça des fois
les parties commencent sans qu'ils
non ça va commencer
on regarde comme tout ça là non
dit que Kaisa la déesse des échecs a
puni Ali resa et Magnus pour leur manque
de fidélité
c'est vrai que à côté de ça
et Kawana c'est des trailer ils sont
toujours là ah oui non mais c'est clair
leur victime du jour c'est clair
alors je te propose que dès que la
partie
d'un magreton commence et ben on la
suivent clairement parce que bon cette
partie c'est la première partie qui
reste et je pense que ça va faire tous
les cas donc je garde un œil sur le
département
et
puis
et puis dès que dès que ça commence on y
va
pour l'instant au niveau des résultats
je peux vous les montrer si vous voulez
les résultats sont ici affichées
parce que c'est mais on a oui c'est un
magasin on a trois zéro pour
carwana contre Magnus je vous rappelle
quand on gagne la partie
lente on gagne 3 points blocage 3 à 0
sur Ali resa aussi et
donc ça quand même deux gros chocs tu
vois
quinzaine et firou c'est quand même deux
des gros des gros favoris de ce tournoi
qui ont perdu leur première partie
classique
et tari qui ont fait nul et ma mégaroc
qui a gagné l'Armageddon c'est pour ça
un et demi à 1 comme je l'avais annoncé
tu avais parié sur Paris j'avais parié
sur ma mais ça fait un peu
dans notre concours de pronostic
Manchester
parce que parce que tu as parlé mais bon
évidemment mais en vrai je non en vrai
je pense que si je suis honnête avec toi
je pense que j'aurais pas eu son tarif
parce que bon bah écoute en amont il
marche pas mal parce qu'on en est la clé
noire bon il peut faire nul bon c'est
pas clair c'est très chaud c'était très
chaud voilà donc là on voit que les deux
autres sont en magasin
américaine que les joueurs avaient été
nuls donc un petit spoil et donc on va
aller sur les
[Musique]
hop je remets la partie mais j'ai pas
moi la partie elle joue encore
les joueurs sont partis quand même
je pense que dans cette position ils se
sont simplement serré la main et c'est
bien légitime
donc c'est terminé il reste donc deux
parties d'Armageddon je vais voir si ça
a commencé j'ai vu qu'elle était déjà
placé là
comme ça a pas commencé et ben écoute je
ne te propose
qu'on regarde
la confession les confessions des
joueurs ah oui j'ai eu des confessions
qui sont
arrivés pendant que ça jouait
just sec
[Musique]
du grand classique qui nous dit qu'en
Armageddon il y a qu'une seule manière
de jouer pour le gain c'est attaque
attaque sacrifié sacrifié
et il était assez content de lui il a
dit je sais pas si c'était correct mais
j'ai bien kiffé donc tant mieux nous on
est content de voir charia content ok
alors là j'en ai plein qui arrivent
encore si vous voulez là on est encore
un petit peu de temps je pense qu'on
peut encore un ou deux avant
l'Armageddon j'ai
j'ai
attends j'ai tari aussi après sa défaite
start tweet
game McQueen
[Musique]
logiquement et qui s'attendait
exactement par de charia se faire
attaquer fort il était forcément déçu
d'avoir joué Damas 2 échec et de se
faire enfermer la dame et il espère
pouvoir faire mieux dans les jours qui
viennent yes donc je débute partir
à côté du de
l'interview de Ariane tari je voulais
pas couper au milieu donc là c'est la
partie qui a commencé donc on voit que
c'est ce Wesley blanc avec maintenant 8
minutes contre 6 donc
à moi qu'il faut hyper vite dans cette
partie donc c'est 10 minutes contre 7
minutes n'a qu'à moi avec les noirs a le
droit de faire nul en cas de nul de la
part de Maka et ben tout simplement il
gagnera l'Armageddon cette fois Wesley a
refusé de rentrer dans dans les grandes
variantes j'ai l'impression dans les
variantes par exemple à berlinoise
qu'il a évité ses lignes ou alors c'est
Naka qui a évité attends il y a eu un
cavalier G4
piano et du coup il va pouvoir jouer
tranquillement pour le gain Wesley à
essayer en tout cas
de la part des blancs
et Naka qui commence un peu à réfléchir
donc il a mis son roi chute c'est parce
qu'il veut jouer avec F5
ouais bah il va vouloir jouer F5 ça
c'est clair mais généralement quand on
peut jouer F5 tu veux attendre que la
position se ferme ou quoi donc on sait
pas sur un coup comme des 5 tu aurais
vraiment une horreur pour les pour les
blancs premièrement à cause du fous
c'est quand qu'il serait enfermé mais en
plus ça ferait un peu avec F5 style est
indienne où là je l'attaque avec toutes
les pièces bien placées
qui ressemble à qui ressemble un peu
maladroite ouais mais tu vois c'est elle
est là parce que cavaillage
on joue souvent nul
compétition et le problème c'est que ben
c'est Armageddon donc la répétition
il peut pas se le permettre non donc il
a fait tour 2 qui est le coup pour jouer
mais maintenant bah ça c'est davantage
et ces inconvénients
il va y arriver en F4 un jour
mais comme c'est fermé la position il a
le temps un peu de faire ce qu'il veut
tu vois il y a 5 minutes à la pendule
contre 7 donc attention attention faut
pas que Nakamura
non c'est parti de Blitz
c'est un vrai danger public aux échecs
rapides sans doute un des meilleurs
joueurs dans les cadences plus ça va
vite plus il est fort
là effectivement il lui reste juste le
problème de son foodcesse blanche à
régler mais celui-ci maintenant il peut
plus trop sacrifier en H3 parce que
c'est quand même bien bien protégé mais
il avait ce genre d'idée la Caval il va
arriver en G6 en F4 que vont faire les
blancs j'ai trois 7 sans doute 3
faiblissant
j'ai trois c'est un coup qui pète pas
mal du tout
derrière
le jeu il est pas encore fermé
mais j'aime bien ces trois mois et il y
a cette tension là qui va bien falloir
résoudre au centre
il va faire G3 mais d'abord petit coup
de fouet fin après ce coup traduit
l'envie de vouloir
mais aussi peut-être des fois l'envie
d'être une pièce en C4
des fois il y a du cavalier 2 qui peut
arriver aussi
il y a eu 4 qui est en prises
mais
il faut voir F5 cavalier H4 bouge madame
je défends quand même pas mal de fois
F5 c'était une possibilité
ce qui va vouloir faire 5 ou pas
un pas simple composant mais mais sans
qu'il réfléchit beaucoup beaucoup à 5
minutes 30 il a déjà pris
ce que déjà rattrapé Hikaru à la pendule
c'est terrible je sais pas quoi faire
c'est pas quoi faire avec les Blancs
il est complètement perdu j'ai envie de
dire que que Naka va gagner son problème
c'est sûr que là j'ai on a peur pour
Wesley forcément
j'ai envie de dire que que
psychologiquement il est un peu dans le
mal
et
après je sais pas
peut-être que
allez F5 donc là il faut voir quelle
manière
ah ouais non mais ça fait un bout de
temps que les noirs sont
sur une position préférable je vais
reprendre du fou c'est bon le fouet
activé forcément
il y a pas le choix
c'est la partie plutôt
il y a pas de clouage il y a peut-être
des idées un jour sur sur F2
même tout de suite ouais un cavalier
tape sur F2 c'est
assez intéressant j'aime beaucoup les
noms en termes de de position je préfère
que quand il attaque
et là on sent qu'il est quelques
problèmes pratiques chez les Blancs à
cause de cette colonne F de foot case
noire mais après ça reste pas mal parce
que même les blancs tu vois ils peuvent
avoir H7 sur les cases blanches surtout
que Naka il a une attaque gratuite là il
a pas de matos et souvent on part de fou
aussi dominante et à un moment ça se
trouve il pourra juste avoir des
perpettes quoi
donc attention le temps qui tu vois le
temps là 4 minutes
Naka qui va qui va bientôt égaliser un
niveau time et donc on a quand même
trois minutes d'avance on commence à
mingans et c'était combien 7 contre 10
et là c'est quatre contre quatre
ça se passe pas bien pour Wesley pas du
tout ce qu'il faut prendre ce Caval F5
qui est un peu embêtant ça veut dire
donner la perte de fou qui à peu près la
seule force des blancs dans cette
position
qui demande les résultats on vous met
les résultats juste après après cette
partie là si je change vous allez pas
voir la partie donc après la partie je
vous montre un peu ce qui se passe en
priorité au direct là parce que c'est
l'armée
gagne ça n'importe quel Tuesday et on
est mardi c'est vrai qu'il y en a qu'à
participer à tous les têtes quand il
peut
et on est mardi donc là c'est un petit
peu la routine c'est sa routine
aujourd'hui
juste le quotidien pour le streamer
américain et côté non streamer ça recule
ça fait
et c'est la cata là pour Wesley
j'ai envie de prendre trois
peut-être c'est pas le plus précis il
faut finir là il a pris des cartes
j'aime bien la présente des quatre aussi
en fait je change
est-ce qu'on peut parce qu'il y a moyen
de pouvoir mettre la pression un peu là
un petit coup de tour à D8 qui va
menacer des trucs
pas mal alors j'ai raté
ah non j'ai mal compté
en fait le pion est emprise
on ne sera pas pourquoi en fait
l'ordinateur il doit se dire que ça rend
l'avantage mais n'a qu'à s'en fiche
puisque ça lui va
besoin de comprendre
et pas du cavalier pourquoi parce que là
je vais prendre des cartes car elle
prend
tour c'est un
devoir bouger le Caval et
ça va pas du tout parce que maintenant
du coup on refait
et avoir le cavalier c'est pas mal
maintenant il y avait deux qui va être
gratuit en fait dans l'autre on prenait
comme ça et directement le processeur
sont en calcula donc
ça c'est parfait c'est parfaitement
organisé ce tournoi norvégien alors FK
donc on va prendre je vois pas trop de
solution j'ai trois
on va jouer cette position qu'un pion de
moins d'un côté avec avec une pièce de
moins côté carreaux
avant qu'il fasse souffre en B2
alors là j'ai plein de choses en prise
il y a la même personne
c'est pas possible
le père NACA là
elle le sait
gagner la partie ah oui là il est très
très détente là je pense
à toi
il a une pièce de plus Wesley quand même
mais bon
mais bon j'ai ça qui est une grosse
menace il vient ici c'est pareil moi
c'est encore mieux d'ailleurs là je
pense avec les idées mais
ça j'ai pas vu tout récent
Tour Eiffel seul coup pour pas se
prendre ton rêve de
et là j'ai une pièce de moi mais j'ai
quand même trois semaines pour la pièce
ça devrait aller parce qu'il va choisir
c'est du carreau je vous rappelle une 45
entre une 33 les joueurs qui sont en
Bullet et qui sont en URL
ultra solide qui envoie un petit C6 des
familles c'était peut-être pas une bonne
idée ça si j'ai pas d'autres
[Musique]
malheureusement j'ai pas d'autres vues à
vous montrer là attention ouais
vous l'avez vu dans le chat
bien sûr vous l'avez vu et n'a qu'à
aussi
mais n'a quatre du coup qui a une tour
passif maintenant alors Wesley qui
serait plutôt d'accord pour échanger les
dames
il a raison de garder la dame un peu
Naka parce que c'est que le roi blanc
est faible donc ça fait des parpettes
aussi
endommagé un peu la structure
il a pas fait le plus simple j'ai
l'impression voilà
je pense qu'il s'attendait à trouver une
petite perpette des fagots quelque part
et puis il a pas eu
tous
une minute chacun là c'est vraiment du
bulletin ambulette je parie ma maison
sur sur ma carte clairement clairement
il est après c'est pas c'est comme si
souvent le Bullet en vrai et sur un vrai
et sur et sur Internet vous savez que là
on peut pas PRIMOVE et il y a pas la
connexion il y a pas tous ces trucs là
c'est vraiment
qu'à qui qui doit juste faire nul ce qui
veut dire que on a qu'à peu flag
détendu surtout Wesley qui n'a pas les
moyens de répéter impossible il faut
gagner
il doit absolument gagner ça et en vrai
c'est peut-être possible il a cavale
déjà il a un cavale ça fait des miracles
43 secondes pour mater en fait
il y a lui qui va tomber
et Naka qui essaie de trouver du lieu
mais qui le trouvera
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
il va manger un pion est-ce que ça va
suffire par exemple un petit BK
tu peux pas il y a cavale des 6 ok il
commence par pousser
ouais attention 30 secondes il y a eu le
tour des deux qui peut arriver attention
tours
c'est pas le moment qui pourrait pêcher
maintenant
ok refuse et voilà il y a des plots qui
commencent à avancer c'est le bordel
c'est marrant parce que sur un vrai
chéquier on arrive moins à jouer vite
naturel
on est plus lent tout le temps sur
internet
mais la six secondes à la pendule je
crois que ça va être flag tous les jours
de là ça va jouer autant
[Musique]
il est en train de l'arnaquer là il est
en train de lui faire à l'ancienne
en même temps il se passe quoi là Wesley
se bat comme un beau diable
allez faut jouer incroyable
on donne tout on donne tout un jour
on va plus rien les gars
c'est le bordel complet les mecs
renversent les pièces c'est n'importe
quoi et c'est où apparemment incroyable
les Norvégiens là c'était dur à suivre
le boulette sans accrément
en vrai c'est marrant mais bon c'est ça
enlève un petit peu le charme des échecs
tu vois à la fin ça mais ok c'est
nerveux la fin là oh là là de ouf et du
coup bah j'ai perdu ma maison
mais vraiment bah je vais la prendre
alors ça me va
donc ok Nakaï c'est énervé non il est
parti au début un peu en colère mais il
est revenu serrer la main après
le pire mauvais perdant devant l'Eternel
ouais mais
du coup ils sont comme serré la main pas
aussi et donc là on va voir la dernière
partie du coup la dernière armage est
donc il devrait commencer je vais voir
si on a la partie et elle a commencé
la partie entre guéri donc c'était 10
minutes contre 7 et là on va virer
quelqu'un qui s'en est bien sorti parce
que on voit autant déjà qui sont pas mal
enfin il a pas revenu des gens je vais
vous mettre la vraie je crois que
c'était le 3
non c'était la 4 et le vrai nom et tout
hein je vous mets les vrais noms et
Abdou qui a des blancs
donc c'est la dernière partie de toutes
les parties ici
allez fous c'est ça
donc voilà rapidement je veux juste
faire l'accélérer pour voir comment on
arrive là on va arriver on va arriver
direct en fait ils ont refait ils ont
refait la partie qu'ils ont qui viennent
de faire en l'an au début ah non cette
fois il a joué une catalane
donc Aniche qui joue une position assez
égalisante et la raison il a les Noirs
il faut qu'il fasse nul
voilà la jauge qui fait des
allers-retours
qui est intéressant ce que fait Aniche
pour surtout pas lâcher une once de
terrain
et
[Musique]
très intelligent c'est 5 évidemment il
faut tout de suite frapper parce que
sinon elle est noire vont ils auraient
jouer peut-être du Caval C6 B7
sinon c'est moi qui vais venir comme tu
l'as dit bloquer un peu ce pion isolé
donc c'est 5 c'est important en plus il
y a un vis-à-vis il faut mettre la
pression dessus derrière
[Musique]
en B4 mais bon ça va difficile
ouais je pense mon prochain coup
maintenant
[Musique]
ouais je pense que à Nice a complètement
égalisé
je suis d'accord je vois pas du tout
ça a l'air dur de chercher un avantage
dans cette position
qui prend tout son temps voilà juste un
petit coup de H6
soit pas du tout anus
en vérité je parlais de
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
surprise le roi qui se rapproche un peu
de l'action
changer les pièces
a été joué et là j'ai plein de
comment dire
de confession qui arrive mais on pourra
pas toutes les voir aujourd'hui parce
que ça ça va dans la partie mais la une
que j'aimerais peut-être éventuellement
bien voir si vous le voulez et celle de
Hikaru post game oh oui oh on a envie de
la voir celle-là
après la partie
la partie qu'il a qui vient de se faire
flag mais après bon un gars ou c'est
quand même le grand maître plage
champion du monde du flag donc bon en
tout cas ça crée Wesley on l'attendait
pas
il nous a bien surpris quand même
c'était pas désagréable j'ai cinq c'est
malin de la part d'Aniche
ouais ils vont pêcher l'extension des
blancs et gagner des cases
est fixé le pion sur G4
ah bah tiens on l'a appelé
comme tu n'as plus de maison sache qu'il
y a pas mal de chouettes maison en
Belgique ah mais c'est un peu loin la
Belgique malheureusement
c'est un peu loin de chez moi
ça peut être n'importe où chez toi c'est
ouf bah oui c'est moi j'habite voilà
Valence c'est moi c'est une grande
maison
de Belgique
[Musique]
après la Belgique c'est sympa un moment
j'avais pensé
il y a peut-être un an ou deux j'avais
pensé
et j'ai pensé à Bruxelles vraiment
mais au final
je pars en Espagne
mais peut-être un jour peut-être un jour
qui remet son cavalier en Détroit
non non il était en F3 tout à l'heure
mais voilà qui recule son cavale
c'est-à-dire qu'ils cherchent des
solutions et qu'il en trouve pas quoi
ouais c'est dur je trouve que c'est très
très bien ce qui nous a fait la niche je
vois pas du tout à passer en fait les
murs sont mieux quoi le pion B5 qui
touche pas le fouet 8 est inébranlable
en fait c'est parce que là tu peux
tomber deux fois qu'il y avait ces
quatre
même pas même pas tu mets ton cavale en
C4 tu le laisses là attends
l'ordi déteste le coup c'est 6 on s'est
compréhensible d'ailleurs ça a été joué
ça
pourquoi on prendrait pas simplement de
en cesser en fait il dit que c'est un
cours à TF1 c'est un c'est un mauvais
coup je pense que c'est ici qui
considère que il a atteint un gain qui
avait ses cartes apparemment super et
pourquoi OK
ou je prends l'intermédiaire ok bon ok
d'accord et c'est pour ça en fait que
comme il a raté quel C4 il faut se dire
que c'est pas bon c'est pas mauvais coup
en soi
et tu reprends les trois qui va forcer
l'abandon
[Musique]
donc
on en parlait de lui comme quoi c'était
un très très grand talent peut-être
futur champion du monde les balins à
cette partie de Blitz il a rien obtenu
contre Guiri Aniche c'est vraiment un
des meilleurs talent qui arrive vraiment
sur la masse mais
il y a encore beaucoup de choses à faire
tu vois c'est un grand favori pour moi
dans cette mission enfin moi je te
montre je t'avais dit mais
quand même il faut confirmer encore et
peut-être que le format le barème de
bien pas trop vrai avec le 3 par
victoire avec le avec le 1/2 point pour
victoire en live il va me perdre quand
même pas mal de points ils perd il a
deux points de retard déjà sur carwana
sur le bouquet donc peut-être ce format
c'est pas le meilleur pour lui
et là il a globalement
donc les résultats sont affichés tout à
l'heure on voulait vouliez sur le sur le
chat donc karwana qui va 3-0 cartel
parce que je vous rappelle que la
victoire est à 3 points en classique
Google qui bat à l'IRESA on a même un et
demi à 1 qui veut dire que 1 1 en terme
de
partie à lente et m'avait dit va gagner
leur magueton a gagné l'Armageddon et
Wesley a gagné l'Armageddon donc les
résultats
vous les avez ici vous avez aussi
maintenant ici qui était mis à jour le
classement
ici et si vous voulez on peut finir le
stream avec éventuellement la dernière
vidéo de Nakamura qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez
moi je suis j'ai envie de le voir
beaucoup de sel dans cette vidéo je
pense qu'on va être
ok je m'attendais à pire ouais il était
surprenament calme il a dit que c'était
pas si difficile de passer du format
long au format Armageddon parce que
temps il y avait pas d'incrément et
qu'il était surtout déçu d'avoir cette
raté tactiquement en fait parce que
c'est ce qui s'est passé globalement le
fou qui donne en G3 il a pas à le donner
et qu'il était plutôt tranquille avec ça
ok bah écoute super je pensais que
ça va être plus trash d'ailleurs à
l'extérieur on est pas moqueur mais
comment il s'agit de Nakamura bon bah ma
caméra c'est un peu le trashTalker si tu
veux bien connu d'Internet tout ça donc
en fait n'a qu'un problème bien moi oui
si jamais on se moquait de lui mais en
tout cas on espérait enfin moi
j'espérais une interview un petit peu
plus un peu plus marrante bon moi j'ai
pas encore écouté je voudrais après
parce que malheureusement comme je suis
lost je peux pas l'écouter en même temps
que je stream malheureusement
mais voilà en tout cas merci pour le
stream Antoine ben merci à toi merci à
toi c'est tout et puis on se retrouve
demain pour de nouvelles aventures
pour la ronde 2 donc merci à tous
d'avoir bien sûr suivi le tri etc et
donc c'était super
je vous souhaite à tous de passer une
agréable soirée et puis on se voit
demain à partir de 17h voilà voilà merci
à tous bonne soirée Ciao